Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Heat. [music]
Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
[music] Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
>> Marinata.
Happy Sabbath everyone and welcome to
our afternoon session here for our
special teach us to pray prayer summit.
How many of you have been blessed
already? Amen.
>> All right. Praise the Lord. I hope that
after lunch you went and you did a
digestion walk so that the blood can
start flowing up and we take prayer
extra seriously and people start praying
all this session. Um, but before we
bring out our speaker, I just want to
remind you we have a special gift that
we are giving to uh those that are
watching us online to teach us to pray.
And you can receive this pocketbook if
you are in the United States of America
and you text the word pray 26 to number
40544.
Or you can scan that QR code that you
see there and you can receive a free
digital copy. You can also visit amazing
afsummit.org
org and you can receive this gift to
help us to learn how to draw closer to
the Lord. Also, a reminder, we're going
to have at 4:00 a Q&A. And so, there's a
that QR code that you're going to see on
screen now. You can scan it and you can
put your uh questions. All right, this
is a specific question one uh in regards
to any question you might have in
regards to prayer or your relationship
with the Lord. And of course, the
speakers will come out at 4:00 and do
that. We also want to let you know that
this is being translated through uh AI
into a number of different languages.
And so if you know of somebody that has
does not speak English and would
benefit, there's the QR code for uh
other languages that you might receive
and so they can enjoy it. Also, I also
want to tell you something very special
for those that come tomorrow morning.
Remember, tomorrow morning, we have a
special morning session. For those that
come tomorrow morning, you will receive
a special prayer journal, right? is
going to be a prayer workshop. So, if
you come tomorrow morning, you will be
able to receive this blessing and this
gift. That said, I'm going to call out
Pastor Jeff Walper, who is the uh the
outreach uh pastor here at the Granite
Bay Hilltop and uh and a friend, a
colleague, a brother, and he's going to
have a word of prayer for us as we begin
this session.
>> Let's bow our heads. Father, we thank
you so much for the word that we've
heard today and last night. We want to
pray prayers of righteous men and women
that will be heard on high. We know that
you're ready to come and take your
people home. And so we ask that you
would prepare our hearts to receive the
message you have for us through Elder
Paige. Anoint us each one with the Holy
Spirit. Anoint Elder Paige with the Holy
Spirit. And help us Lord to prepare for
this loud cry, this latter rain, this
finishing work in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And so, as Jess mentioned, our
speaker is going to be uh Pastor uh
Elder Paige, Jerry Paige. For those that
were not here last night, he was a
conference president. He worked at the
GC. He's a retired pastor now. And he
wanted me to say that he loves his
family. And uh he loves the Lord
immensely. So, you will be blessed.
>> And I'm not as old as it seems. You
know,
>> I've been greatly blessed in this
meeting already. Have you? I've had a
lot of good responses from you and I
know the Holy Spirit is doing his job in
each one of us. And as I said yesterday,
um I really believe that what those of
us who are speaking up front say might
be helpful to you, but what the Holy
Spirit whispers to you can change your
life dramatically. So I love that
statement again that Ellen White said
that we can learn more from the Holy
Spirit in one moment than from all the
great men of the world in a lifetime.
So, I'd like to give you a chance again
in in secret prayer, silent prayer, to
just give consent to the Holy Spirit.
The Father will give him to you and when
he comes, he'll bring all the things you
need and all the instruction and and
whisper to you what you need to hear
during this message. So, let's pray
silently. Tell God you give him
permission to send the Holy Spirit to do
what he wants to in your life.
Lord, we give this time to you. Uh you
are so precious. You have loved us and
favored us and followed us all our
lives. And we want this weekend to be
more than meetings. We want it to be
life-changing. for those around the
world who are just [clears throat]
finishing up the 10 days of prayer, many
of them, we just ask that you would put
a special uh double anointing of the
Holy Spirit's power and presence on all
of us. And we thank you in Jesus name.
Amen.
>> I shared a little last night about
Janet's experience and mine a number of
years ago when God had to reignite our
experience. She was very depressed and I
became a president and I wasn't
sensitive enough as a husband to
understand that she was not making it
with God and about giving up all that.
But after God turned us around because
of the prayers of our people in
Pennsylvania for us, uh she began to be
so in love with Jesus and her prayer
time was on fire. So several women in in
the United States asked her to go with
them. They were going to Russia. The
walls had just come down and they said,
"Janet, we want you to come and go with
us on this trip. We're going to go
around Russia a number of places and
we're going to be talking to the women
especially who were lived under
communism. They don't know much about
knowing Jesus or praying have experience
with him and we want you to go with us.
So she came she said JJ what should I do
should going on this trip and I said oh
Janet that would be great you'll grow be
wonderful for you and your your
experience now with love of Jesus and
your prayer time would be a great
blessing to those women. She said but
Jerry we have two sons remember. She
said, "You know what'll happen? I'm
going for three weeks. What would happen
to them?" I said, "No problem. I'll take
care of it. I'll be Mr. Mom." Huh? I
didn't know what I didn't know. You know
what I'm saying? Anyway, but she took
food, put it in the freezer, got things
pretty well ready for us, and off she
went to Russia. And I, as president,
became, and I don't know how to cook, I
don't know how to do anything. I became
Mr. Mom. But anyway, um went pretty well
for a little while, for maybe two weeks.
But about two weeks in, I was getting
very grouchy. Uh wanted mama to come
home.
And uh we were sitting at the supper
table eating spaghetti. Tyson's one of
them. You may know she her husband now.
Tyson was one of our sons. The other one
was Zach. He was younger. They were
eating. We were eating spaghetti. I did
get that ready for them. So anyway, as
we're eating the spaghetti, Zach is
playing with his spaghetti airplane. You
know what I'm saying?
Into his mouth. They thought it was
really funny. I didn't think it was
funny. I said, "Zack, will you sit up to
the table and eat right? Do you you want
to spill spaghetti sauce on your pants?
We'll have to wash your clothes again.
Just sit up and eat right." So both of
them are stone cold silent. Oh, dad's
going off again, you know. So, I I take
the spaghetti sauce jar because we need
a little more warmed up. I take it out
to the kitchen. I put it in the
microwave. And uh [laughter]
when it came time to take it out,
remember I don't cook and I took it out.
I burned my little preacher fingers and
and I just went like that. It smashed on
the floor. Painted the whole kitchen
with spaghetti sauce.
I have never heard my boys laugh so hard
in their entire lives. Oh, daddy says,
"Sit up to the table and eat right." and
you know, don't spill sauce on your
pants. And then he paints the whole
kitchen with it.
I love Jesus more with him. He has a way
when I'm getting arrogant and I'm
pointing at you and telling you what
you're doing wrong and I'm being nasty
and harsh, he has a way of humbling me,
right? What's the Bible say? Lift
yourself up, judge others, and you'll
have to be humbled to save you. Okay? Uh
God has had to do that to me so much in
my life and I praise him that he's like
that. Um I heard a story not long after
I went to the GC. The the new president
of Southwestern University came to me
and he said, "Jerry, I heard a funny
story one of the faculty told me the
other day." He said, you know, he was
asked to preach to our convocation at
the university and he said all the staff
were there, the faculty and and you
know, everyone was there, the students.
And he said it was a big day for him.
And so he said, "I was preaching in
front of the people and I was preaching
on the subject of humility." And as I
was preaching, you know, the people were
really with me. I mean, you can tell,
you know, Sket says, "Say amen." But
they were they were fervent, tears in
their eyes, the whole thing. But anyway,
um he said, you know, I knew I really
had them and and they were really with
me and and God was moving. And he said,
"As I began to preach more and more, I
thought, you know, this is really a good
sermon.
This is one of the best sermons I've
ever preached." He said, you know, he
said, more I went along, yeah, the
people were moving and I was thinking,
you know, I bet this is better than
Billy Graham preaches.
And he said, so anyway, when I got to
the end, I made an appeal. People were
sitting there with tears in their eyes,
thinking about being humble servants for
Jesus and everything. And I went off the
platform after prayer and went into the
side room. And I just couldn't help it.
I said, "Be jealous, Billy Graham." But
I forgot to turn off my neck mic.
and it went booming out over the whole
congregation. So,
kind of ruined my sermon on humility. I
love CD Brooks. He was a great black
preacher in our church, evangelist.
Wasn't he great? And he was there when I
first came out of drugs, went to
Andrews, and I just listen to his tapes
over and over again. The the fire and
the power. But, uh, he said one time, he
said, "I'm very careful how I pray for
humility.
Uh, I say, Lord, please humble me in
private with you."
>> Yes. So, so that I won't have to be
humiliated in public. Amen.
Yeah. Humility. Got to be careful about
praying for that. Um Janet and I, as I
told you, uh we traveled a lot for 12
years with the general conference. And
to those of you around the world that we
saw in these different cultures and all,
thank you for your kindness, your
hospitality, your love. We had a great
time and we have wonderful pictures and
wonderful memories of it all. Glad
you're with us in this summit. But uh
we'd been teaching in New Zealand for a
week, pastors and leaders there and she
was working of course with pastors
families and and other prayer ministries
which she carried. And so anyway, we
were at the end of that week we were
tired and u but our next appointment was
Mongolia. So we flew up to Mongolia
already tired and it's a great country.
Church isn't too old there. A lot of
young pastors and everything. So we we
taught for another week up there. By
that time we were really exhausted and
so but our next our next appointment was
China Beijing and that was exciting. We
hadn't been to China yet and you know
the the people there even under
communism they had 500,000 members. The
Holy Spirit's been working in China and
we couldn't wait to get there and our
role was to try to talk to the elders
and pastors about prayer and revival and
reformation and how to really be
spiritual leaders for God. So, we get to
the hotel door that night and uh we were
really exhausted after those other two
weeks and travel. At the door, Janet
said something to me and I tell you,
Janet is wonderful wife. I just love her
so much and she's been a great team
member. But that night, she said
something to me and I uh thought it was
one of those smart remarks. You know
what I mean? Think that I I would
misunderstand. But anyway, I
misunderstood her. But that kind of
upset me. And so I said something back
to her that wasn't very nice. Well, that
made her mad, you know. So she said
something to back to me that wasn't nice
and that really ticked me off. So I said
something to her that was really, really
not nice. And back and forth, boom. I
mean, we had a big explosion. You never
have that happen. Now you're listening
to a preacher and his wife that do that.
But [clears throat]
we really didn't want to go in the same
room that night. We wished we could have
two rooms, but we couldn't. So we go in
there. none of this get making
everything right before you go to sleep.
We were both really mad and we don't do
that. So, we went to bed angry.
So, what do you do? You're supposed to
get up in the morning and go talk to the
leaders in China about how to be
wonderful Christlike leaders, right? And
you're not getting even speaking to your
wife. So, in the morning, we woke up
fairly early and we always try to have
time with Jesus to spend time especially
when we're ministering and everything,
but every day. And uh so we she got down
on one side of the bed and I was on the
other side of the bed. We were having
our worship and you know what the Holy
Spirit was doing, right?
Whacking us both upside of the head of
what we had to do. So we ended up in the
end knowing that we needed to go and
apologize to each other. And u so we
went around the end of the bed, looked
at each other, went around the end of
the bed, I apologized to her, she
apologized to me, we ended up embracing
and we went off to teach for Jesus
Christ. Do you ever go through those
kind of things? Seems like whenever you
got a major opportunity to do something
for Jesus, the devil gets in there and
tries to flip a switch, try to trigger a
relationship, right? So, I want to be
talking today about uh thriving
relationships. No limits in thriving
relationships. I'm sure in this church,
I hear you all get along great. You work
through your problems, no problem. So, I
know there's no relationship problems,
but there may be guests here, right?
Come from other churches that are having
problems. Anyway, u I've discovered as I
look back over my life and my ministry
that most of the things that have
happened to me that are, you know,
conflict or tension, uh that are, you
know, hurt feelings, relationship
problems, marriage, ministry, the whole
life deal with me being offended self
somehow. I don't get the respect I think
I should have gotten. My opinion is not
regarded the way I want it to be. I uh,
you know, I begin to defend myself. I
begin to protect it. At times I want to
exalt myself and people don't give me
enough exaltation.
You don't have a problem with any of
this, do you?
Yeah. Indulging it. Pride of opinion. On
and on it goes. Um,
thank God that he helps us with self.
Amen.
>> Because relationships get messed up
every time by self. It goes clear back
to Satan, right? He for some strange
reason wanted to be God instead of just
under Jesus. What a mess that's caused
for us. And it really ties back to
desire to protect self and do things for
self and whatever. There was a very
successful young u leader in the church.
He was well thought up. He was moving up
the ladder in the church. He was very
harsh. He knew he was right about
everything. Um he was zealous, proud,
but he had it all wrong. You know who
I'm talking about, right? Philippians
chapter 3. Yeah, it's that uh Saul that
became Paul. Uh amazing young successful
leader in the church, but he didn't
understand at all.
Philippians 3 3-9. Follow along in your
Bible if you want. Did they pass out a
hand up to you this afternoon?
Yeah. Good. U basically that's in the
book we're going to be giving you too,
but it's to follow along a little bit if
you want to when we get to another part
of this talk. Paul says this,"For we are
the circumcision who worship God in the
spirit, rejoice in Christ Jesus, and
have no confidence in the flesh." Mark
that one down, right? No confidence in
the flesh. Though I also might have
confidence in the flesh. If anyone else
thinks he may have confidence in the
flesh, I more so. Circumcised the eighth
day of the stock of Israel, of the tribe
of Benjamin, a Hebrew of the Hebrews. He
was a seventh day Adventist of the
Seventh Day Adventists. Amen. He knew it
all. Concerning the law, I was a
Pharisee. Concerning zeal, persecuting
the church. Concerning the righteousness
which is in the law, blameless. But what
things were gained to me? These I have
counted loss for Christ. Yet indeed I
also count all things loss for the
excellence of what?
knowing Jesus, the knowledge of Jesus
Christ, for whom I have suffered the
loss of all things, and count them as
rubbish, that I may gain Christ and be
found in him, not having my own
righteousness, which is from the law,
but that which is through faith in
Christ, the righteousness which is from
God by faith. How is it with you? How is
it with me? Are we sometimes proud of
our knowledge, all the doctrines we
know, and the activities that we're
doing, that kind of thing? I want to uh
read another statement that I didn't get
in the PowerPoint this time, but I think
it's of real value. Um,
let me see if I can find it here now.
Yeah.
No, I don't have it. Okay, forget that.
Desire of Ages page 362 talks about the
Pharisees and the rabbis. How they had
were so proud of their activities. They
were so busy for the Lord. They were
doing all this stuff for the the temple
and for the church and all these things
and how they actually began to make a
savior of their activity. It says, "And
we have the same danger today where we
get so busy doing for God or doing other
things or whatever that we we drift away
and our our connection with Jesus is
ruined. we don't have the same
connection because we've drifted. We
begin to trust and and then the more
successful we are in doing all these
things. Uh the more danger there is in
us trusting to the methods and the plans
that we do and not trusting in Jesus.
And it goes on to say only the work that
is bathed with much prayer and the
righteousness of Jesus Christ will prove
effective in the end. So the danger I'm
sure amazing facts uh people and all we
we are busy for the Lord. We're trying
to win souls. I mean, that's something
this this organization is great. All
over the world, we saw amazing facts and
and the ministries that they're doing.
It's so beautiful. But, you know, I've
been around the world, too, and I've
seen that most of us as church leaders
and even as as local church leaders, uh,
we we get kind of proud of our
activities sometimes. Oh, I'm busy. The
[clears throat] general conference
cafeteria, you know, how are you? Oh,
I'm busy, man. I'm in jetlag. I just got
back from blah blah blah blah. you know,
and you can get into that mode where
somehow the activities we're doing, the
methods and all that is what it's all
about instead of knowing Jesus and
really having that relationship with him
and giving him all the glory and the
credit for everything that we do. So
Paul makes it clear, but then I love
Philippians 2 and I want to focus on
that in the time we have this afternoon.
One of the greatest passages in all of
scripture. For therefore, if there is
any consolation in Christ, if any
comfort of love, any fellowship of the
spirit, if any affection and mercy,
fulfill my joy by being likeminded,
having the same love, being of one
accord, of one mind.
Let nothing be done through selfish
ambition or conceit, but in loneliness
of mind, let each esteem others better
than themsel. Let each of you look not
only for your own interests, but also
for the interests of others.
Let this mind be in you which was also
in Christ Jesus. What a text, right? Let
this mind be in you which was also in
Christ Jesus. And of course then he goes
on, we won't look at that
right now, but he says he was God.
Thought it not robbery to equal God, but
he what became a man and then a servant
and a humble and naked on a tree. He
died humbled far greater than anybody in
the universe. And yet that is the
principle of the Bible. when you put
yourself down, God exalts you. So it
says, so the father has exalted him
above every other name. Amen. That
throughout eternity, Jesus will be
praised more than anybody else. So what
a beautiful thing this is. But the mind
of Christ, uh verse five there is what I
want to focus on because the
relationship problems that we have, if
we have the mind of Jesus, we will
thrive in them. They will go away. We
can deal with it. We'll talk about a lot
of practics on that this afternoon and
how prayer fits into that whole
relationship. But Paul says, "Have the
mind of Jesus. Have the joys of being
dead to self, buried in resurrection
with Jesus, living every day in humble
service and love, and giving
unselfishness to others instead of
taking all the time." Um, I want to read
now some statements from Ellen White
that are powerful on the joys of being
dead. I don't know how your theology of
being dead is, but we're supposed to be
dead, right? Have the joy and and the
thriving comes from being dead. This one
uh from Mount of Blessings, page 16.
It is the love of self that destroys our
peace. Do you have peace today? Perfect
peace. I struggle with that. Just having
peace, you know, but it's always about
self. That's what she says. While self
is all alive, we stand ready continually
to guard it from mortification and
insult. But when we are dead and our
life is head with Christ in God, we
shall not take neglects or slights to
heart, we should be deaf to reproach and
blind to scorn and insult. How's it
going on in your life that way? Can
anybody offend you? Can anybody insult
you? Those who are dead to self, she
says, and this is from uh second volume
of testimonies 4:25. Those who are dead
to self will not feel so readily, will
not be prepared to resist everything
which may irritate. Dead man cannot
feel. That's our theology, right?
Spiritually too. You are not dead. If
you were and your life were hid in
Jesus, a thousand things which you now
notice, which afflict you, would be
passed by as unworthy of notice. You
would then be grasping the eternal and
would be above the petty trials of life.
I long for that. Don't you? That kind of
experience. And then this next one is
what the title's from. No limits.
Thriving in our relationships. thriving
in our life with Jesus. She says in
ministry of healing, there's no limit to
the usefulness of one who putting God
putting self aside, I can see it up
there too, makes room for the working of
the Holy Spirit upon his heart and lives
a life wholly consecrated to God. All
who consecrate body, soul, and spirit to
his service will be constantly receiving
a new endowment of physical, mental, and
spiritual power. The inexhaustible
supplies of heaven are at their command.
Christ gives him the breath of his own
spirit, the life of his own life. The
Holy Spirit puts forth the highest
energies to work in mind and heart. And
through the grace given us, we may
achieve victories that because of our
own erroneous and preconceived opinions,
our defects of character, our smallness
of faith have seemed impossible. Yeah.
No limit to the usefulness of one who
puts self aside. That's easy though,
isn't it? Putting self aside. Let's just
do that. Let me just tell you, let's put
self aside. Grit your teeth and do it.
Does it work?
No. I wanted the last time I have here
to try to give you practice. And some
ways we can actually do that because and
it it got a lot to do with prayer. I've
discovered if we're going to put self
aside, we need to have a lot of
communion with Jesus and know how we're
dealing with that. But what a what a
promise that is. No limits to the
usefulness of if we can do that. So,
we'll go on with that. Um
then there's another statement that she
makes.
Okay.
Am I going the right way here? If pride
and selfishness were laid aside, five
minutes would remove most difficulties.
Got any difficulties in your marriage?
I'm going to tell you a story a little
later about a marriage that got rid of
it all in five minutes or so. Half an
hour maybe. Five minutes would remove
most of the difficulties in our church,
our families, our our ministry, our
children, the whole thing. And this
statement, if we would humble ourselves
before God and be kind and courteous and
tender-hearted and pitiful, there would
be how many? You've heard it before. A
100 conversions
to the truth where now there's only one.
But though professing to be converted,
we carry around with us a bundle of self
that we regard as altogether too
precious to be given up. Lord, I would
like that. Help me. Help me to be
humble, gentle, not explosive, not
protective of self, so that I can win a
lot more people to you. Amen. And I can
tell you that's Christ's method alone to
do that. Um, I'm going to take just a
minute that's not on the screen, but I
want to share a couple more things with
you that way. Um,
see, I think I'm done with those. Yeah.
It is our privilege to lay this burden
at the feet of Jesus. in its place take
the character and similitude of Christ.
Uh this booklet you'll be getting has
these statements on a couple of pages. I
just read you several of them but it
also has a a section called dying to
self. And I these things are really
convicting to me.
When you're forgotten or neglected or
purposely said it not and you don't
sting and hurt with the insult of the
oversight but your heart is still happy
being counted worthy to suffer for
Christ. That is dying to self. When your
good is evil spoken of, when your wishes
are crossed, when your advice is
disregarded, your opinions ridiculed,
your best intentions misinterpreted, you
refuse to let anger rise in your heart
or even defend yourself, but rather take
it all in patient, loving silence,
knowing that Christ alone is your
defender. That's dying self. Lord, help
me.
When you don't care to refer to yourself
in conversation. When you don't feel the
need to boast of your accomplishments
and record every good deed you do for
the world to see. When you don't itch
after commendation and applause. When
you don't mind when others are
acknowledged and your name is ignored.
When you're more concerned with being
faithful to God's call. When you're okay
with being unknown. That is dying to
self. How are you doing with those? I It
convicts me. When you when you receive
correction and reproof from one of less
stature than yourself and can humbly
submit inwardly as well as outwardly,
finding no rebellion or resentment
rising up within your heart,
that's dying to self.
In these last days, the spirit must
bring us to the cross if we would be
saved. Amen.
And once we die on the cross, we will
not respond any slice against our human
flesh any longer because dead people
don't move.
I'm crucified with Christ. Nevertheless,
I live, Paul said. Yet not I, but Christ
lives in me. Lord, help me have the joys
of being dead.
>> Amen.
>> I want that. Don't you? It is how we
thrive in life as a Christian. And yet,
it is so so difficult in so many ways.
Um, how does this work in life? Let me
tell you an illustration. I How does
this humility, this selflessness work
with prayer? Um, I have two sons.
Tyson's a assistant district attorney
here in Roseville for the Pler County.
Uh helps run the Lincoln church. My
other son's a pastor now. But in high
school, Zach had a bit of problems. And
one day the school called and told
Janet, "Zack is on his way home. We
lived about 45 minutes from the school
in Fresno."
And uh he gotten kicked out. So anyway,
Janet was at home. I was traveling. I
wasn't around as as often was the case.
So all of a sudden, Janet, my precious
wife, was saying, "Okay, my son's coming
home. He's 17 years old. He's already
getting a bit of an attitude, and he's
coming home. He's been suspended from
school. What do I do? What do I say?"
And she was talking to God. She started
talking to God, of course, right away.
She said, "Lord, why would Zach do this?
It was some kind of silly. And why would
he do this? We trained him better than
this. He didn't have to do that. Why
would he do it? And what am I going to
say to him when he gets home?" So, she's
talking to God and God is listening and
God is going to start talking to her.
And as as she was talking to him, she
began to feel that God was saying, "Why
don't you ask me if what you might have
done that would have made him think this
wasn't that bad?"
But Janet immediately reacted against
that. I've never done anything like
that. I, you know, there's nothing like
that that I've done. And she resisted
that. She went on praying, "Lord, tell
me what I'm going to say. how am I going
to handle him when he gets home in the
best way under your your love? And so
anyway, but as she kept praying, he kept
pressing her with this thought. Why
don't you ask me what you might have
done that would have made him think it
wasn't so big a deal to do it? So
finally said, "Okay, Lord, what did I
what have I done? It would be anything
like we did that might have given him
permission to do that." And he put in
her mind very clearly something. was a
terrible thing, but it was another
little slippery slope thing that she'd
done. Probably I'd done it with her. And
she's thinking, "Oh, God, are you
kidding me?" And so, she was really
repentant. She began to talk to God
about confessing that she had done that,
whatever it was. And and uh
God forgave her, of course. Then she
began to say, "Well, God, what do I say
to him now when he gets home, though? I
mean, how do I deal with with Zach? I
don't want to push him farther away into
rebellion or anything."
And so he put some things in her mind.
And when Zach came home, uh, he was
coming in the front door and expecting
to really get
lambasted by mom for what he'd done and
scolded and maybe punishments, whatever.
He comes in kind of slouching. He's
tall, 66. And uh, anyway, she says,
"Zack, come on in, sit on the couch. I
need to talk to So he comes in, kind of
throws himself down on the couch, and 17
years old, um, in trouble. Janet said to
him, "Zack, you know, I wondered why you
did what you did. It didn't make sense
to me. You didn't need to do it. I
thought felt like we trained you in
different ways." But she said, "As
[snorts] I was talking to God about it,
God showed me something, Zach. He showed
me that I had done something that might
have made you think it wasn't so bad to
do that." And I really want to apologize
to you, Zach, for that. Would you
forgive me for that?
Can you imagine what that did to that
17-year-old boy?
He gets suspended a month apologize.
We don't do that naturally.
That's something the Holy Spirit can put
in our heart
>> if we spend time with him, if we wait,
if we ask him to give us counsel.
And so I'm I can tell you Zach had his
time just like his dad did. But he's on
fire for Jesus a pastor now in the
Templeton Hills church. We live down
there with him. And it's just amazing
the difference God's made in his life in
the last number of years. So anyway, um
moving on. I want to go now to these
seven principles of thriving and better
relationships. Okay, you've got them on
your sheet. You can follow along a
little, but they'll be on the screen.
And you'll get this book. It's in the
back of this book, too. One of the one
of the chapters there.
And it's called
That They May Be One. Seven Principles
for Better Thriving Relationships. Okay.
[snorts]
I have a job for you right now. I want
you to think of the person you like the
least.
Don't look at me so holy.
you got one like that, you know, may not
be they maybe they abused you, maybe
they've been mean to you, maybe they've
talked behind your back, or maybe
they've just are not the kind of people
you want to hang around with. Person you
like the least. Think about that person
for just a minute. All right.
Have you got one?
Okay.
Jesus prayed in John 17. We looked
through chapter 13 to to 14:15 the other
day. in 17. This is what some call the
real Lord's prayer, you know, where he
was uh we heard brother Ski quote it the
other night by my heart. I that was
impressive. But I just uh this verse 21
17 he says that all of them father he's
talking about us now that all of them
father
would be Oops. I have that scripture.
Yeah. Oops. [snorts] That all of them
may be one father. Just as you are in me
and I am in you, may they also be in us.
Why?
Why? So that the world may believe that
you have sent me. So many myths in the
world. Santa Claus and other gods and
all kinds of religions and everything.
Jesus was praying, "Lord, help the
Christians, my disciples, to be of one
accord the way we are in the Trinity."
Wow. How about that in our marriage?
about that in our church and our
relationships. Help them be that tight
together of one accord that the world
will believe this thing is true that I
really came that I'm the savior of the
world.
Ellen White said it like this. It's not
the opposition of the world that most
endangers the church of Christ. It's the
evil cherished in the hearts of
believers. On the other hand, the
strongest witness that God has sent his
son into the world is the existence of
harmony and you union among men of
varied dispositions who form the church.
Before I retired, I had a little private
exit visit with Ted Wilson at president
of the general conference at the time.
And I'd written an article in Ministry
magazine, really a heart article at the
end for the pastors around the world,
the joys of unselfishness and the joys
of being dead and how much we often when
we're even leaders in the church, we are
so full of self that our people see us
and they see us getting offended. They
see us trying to exalt ourselves and
claw for positions and all that.
And Ted said to me, Jerry, that is
probably the biggest problem holding
back the church.
And I believe that too self coming up
even through leaders in the church and
pastors. And I I urge you to pray for
your pastors. Uh I've been a pastor all
these years and we're human.
We need you praying for us.
Not just criticizing.
Got a lot of good pastors. We got
pastors that aren't so good. But um
the Lord can do mighty things when we
pray for our pastor. We had a there was
a church in our conference when we were
in central won't say what it was but
[snorts]
some ladies that were prayer partners
with Janet came to her and they wanted
to use her to get to the me I was
president to get their pastor changed.
They didn't like their pastor and they
said he doesn't preach you know
prophecy. He doesn't believe in Ellen
White. He doesn't preach the sanctuary
and all these things. And so we wanted
we want Jerry to change the pastor. We
need another pastor. And Janet's answer
to them after thinking about it and the
Lord impressed her was she said, "Have
you prayed for your pastor? Have you
prayed for your pastor?" And they said,
"Oh yeah, we prayed for him. We prayed
for him." She said, "How much should
have you prayed for him?" "Oh, I don't.
We We spent two, three weeks, different
times praying for him, probably." She
said, "No, no, no. I want you to
seriously, intensively pray for a
spiritfilled pastor. pray for a
spiritfilled pastor. She said, 'If God
wants him to stay, he'll stay. God wants
him to leave, maybe that'll happen, too.
So, anyway, those ladies took her
seriously, and they began to do that.
And I'm passing out that document. I
wouldn't worry too much about the
document, guys, at this point. If
anybody needs it, raise your hand. Um,
but anyway, [snorts]
it was almost two years that these
people were praying that and all of a
sudden, they came to Janet. I said,
"Janet, you won't believe what happened
to our pastor. He's been converted. He's
preaching on the sanctuary. He's
preaching on, you know, the prophecies.
We're going to have an evangelistic
meeting." Everything had changed. Their
prayers had changed the pastor instead
of getting them out. Okay. Something to
think about when you're when you're
struggling with pastors. But, okay. Um,
seven principles for thriving
relationships dealing with prayer.
Number one principle is intercede in
prayer for people instead of trying to
change them. What happened to my
scripture there? Instead of trying to
change them or trying to do the Holy
Spirit's work yourself,
you know, we often rush off and try to
fix people, don't we? And we try to to
tell them what they're doing wrong or we
we talk to others about what they're
doing wrong or what some other kind of
thing. I've tried to play the Holy
Spirit so many times in my life, but
[snorts] I I got back from a trip. I had
a departmental director in a conference.
It wasn't central, but I had a
departmental director who
u loved to gossip. He was always saying
negative things about other people,
tearing down their reputation behind
their back. Does that ever happen in
this church?
>> No. Good. I'm glad. Bunch of liars.
[laughter]
[snorts] Anyway,
he said we should repent of our sins
this morning. Remember that?
So anyway, u I had had a conversation
with him as president. I said, "Listen,
man. We work in the office here. We're
leaders in the conference. We got to cut
that out. We just can't be going around
and gossiping on everybody and trying to
tear people down." He was an insecure
person, I think, and when he tore
somebody else down, he thought he'd lift
himself up. Does that work very well?
>> People come to me tearing somebody down,
I'm thinking, I wonder what they're
saying about me behind my back. And I it
doesn't really lift them up. So anyway,
a little later on, I got back from a
trip and I found out this guy had been
doing it again. We had a new young
couple that was evangelistic and
everybody liked them in the conference,
but he had set out to say things about
them to try to tear them down. And then
I found out what he was saying and I
found some of it's just totally not
true. So I thought it really upset me.
It annoyed me. So I told this guy, I
said, you know, I need to meet with you.
I can't today because we meet next
Tuesday in my office. My plan for
behavior modification, you wouldn't want
me as your president. My plan was I had
a little legal brief of what he'd been
doing. I was going to read that to him
and watch him squirm in my office and
then I was going to tell him he needed
to cut it out again and that would
change his behavior. Wouldn't you like
me for your president?
But God stepped in. My precious wife
stepped in. On Mon on Monday before
Tuesday, Janet was at home and I was at
home and I [snorts] told her what I was
going to do. She knew this guy. She knew
his problem. But when she heard what I
was saying, she thought and she's pretty
gracious in the way she counsels me. You
know, you know guys, what wives were
given to us for, right?
In Genesis, what's it saying?
>> Help me. What's that mean? Take care of
the kids, food, clothes, maybe have a
career, whatever. No, if you check that
word out, it really means a counselor,
advisor to give us counsel. Janet has
been a tremendous counselor to me. She's
much more deceptive sometimes about
people than me. Anyway, so I I ran it by
her and she was careful, but she said,
"Well, Jerry, just spend a lot of time
with Jesus before you do it." It's
pretty good counsel, right? I kind of
Oh, yeah. Yeah, sure. Well, the next
day, the next day, I was having my
worship early with the Lord. And you
know, there is a statement that says,
"Our time with God is an audience with
the infinite one. And he will speak to
us as surely as though we could hear it
with our ears." And we need to write
those things down. on this journaling
thing he was talking about. [snorts] I
said, "Lord, lately my devotional life
has been more like a um trying to pull
something out of a dust dusty history
book. I'm not hearing your voice. Please
speak to me. I I love it when you speak
to me. I try to remember and write
things down, but lately it's been dry.
My devotional life has been dry." And so
I asked him to do that. Well, I went
back to where I'd been reading in
Proverbs 20. And you don't need to look
this up, but I was reading again in
Proverbs 12, asking God to speak to me.
20. I'm sorry. And these things began to
jump off the page. I have them
highlighted in yellow now. A fool shows
his annoyance at once. Yeah, I was
annoyed with this guy. I wasn't thinking
about the guy, but it goes on. Reckless
words pierce like a sword, but the
tongue of the wise brings healing. I was
about to cut this guy up on my
presidential carpet and watch him bleed.
There's deceit in the hearts of those
who plot evil, but joy for those who
promote peace. A wise man keeps his
knowledge to himself. I was going to
dump the whole load on this guy. So, I
heard the Lord. I said, "Okay, Lord. I
hear you talking to me. You're you're
saying I'm right about the facts, but
I'm going to be wrong in spirit, right?
I have a friend who says my worst
sinning comes when I'm right."
You hear me? Yeah, that can happen.
Anyway, I said, "Okay, God, I hear you.
I'm not going to be right in spirit. So,
tell me what to do about it." And I
believe the Lord brought to my mind a
text. And it was a text, not a text that
I had necessarily memorized or anything,
but it's this one. Uh, Galatians 6:1-3
just popped in my mind. [snorts]
Brothers, if a man has overtaken any
trespass, you who are spiritual resource
such one in such in a spirit of what?
>> Gentleness. Considering yourself, lest
you also be tempted, bear one another's
burdens. So fulfill the law of Jesus.
For if anyone thinks himself to be
something when he's nothing, he deceives
himself. Wow. I say, "Okay, God, I hear
you. you're telling me to be very
gentle, figure this out. But how can I
do it, Lord? He needs to stop. And so
anyway, as I kept praying, God gave me
some ideas. When I went to meet with him
the next morning, that morning, uh, I
sat down, first thing I said to him, I
said, you know, brother, I have a
problem I want you to pray me about.
Pray for me about. I said, I sometimes
talk about people behind their back in
negative ways, tear their reputation
down. I said, I want you to pray for me
that I'll be more like Jesus. And then I
shared a little bit of what I knew he'd
been doing and he got the point and um
we ended up on our knees praying for
each other, arms around each other with
tears in our eyes. It's much better
behavior modification and I think it
really did help him change. But God
wasn't done with that. That evening I
got home and there was a pastor on the
phone to me in our conference and he was
really angry at his elders. He said,
'You know, Jerry, my elders are going
around behind my back and they're saying
stuff that just is not true, and I'm
going to sit them down tomorrow and I'm
going to really straighten them out.
Isn't God good? He got me up early,
worked me over, gave me a text that I
could say to this pastor, "Hey, slow
down, friend. You're going to end up in
trouble if you do that. Slow down and
treat them as Jesus would treat them."
God is so good. And I love this first
principle of interceding
in prayer for people instead of trying
to change them or trying to be the Holy
Spirit. The Holy Spirit's very able to
do his work, isn't he? We pray for them.
We intercede. Here's some some
understatements there. It's on your
sheet as well. Claim promises like 1
John 5:16 says, you know, if you see a
brother sending a sin, it's not the
unpardonable sin. We can pray and God
will what? Give us life for them. God
will give us life if we come to him and
we wait and we think about here's things
through. As we spend time with the Lord,
he may show us that we've been part of
the problem or set a mirror before us so
he can see our need and change. Huh?
That's what happened to me.
Live the fruit of the spirit and preach
at others less. That would help our
church a lot if we would be like Jesus
instead of trying to tell everybody else
they're not.
Do it. Okay. And then last, take action
only if the Holy Spirit impresses you.
Okay? Instead of me rushing off as an
administrator, a fixer, trying to fix
everybody, I pray a lot first. If God
tells me to do something, then I'll do
it. But if I just rush out, I'll mess
make a mess of it most every time. Okay,
that's principle one
to thriving relationships. Principle two
is to respect the diversity and
temperaments of God's created
differences in people. Yeah, the Lord
has created us differently. Have you
noticed that we're all different parts
of the body? He said, "Some of us are
big mouths. Others are internal organs.
We don't talk much. Some are big toes.
We bring balance. All kinds of different
things. You know how that works. But we
need to realize that that's important in
keeping relationships in one accord. If
we will realize that and slow down a
little before we get so upset that
somebody sees things differently than we
do in a board or wherever it is, we need
to sacredly regard the feelings and
respect the rights of others with whom
God has placed us in relationship." This
statement by Ellen White again from
child guidance. She says, "Mark
diversities of disposition and character
frequently exist in the same family."
Did you notice that?
For it is in the order of God that
persons of varied temperaments should
associate together. God gave you that
spouse that's so different and irritates
you. Huh? Why? On it goes. When this is
the case, each member of the household
should sacred regard the feelings and
respect the rights of others of the
others. By this means mutual
consideration and forbearance will be
cultivated, prejudices will be softened,
and rough points of character smooth.
Harmony may be secured, and the blending
of the very temperaments may be of
benefit to each. I tell Janet, we we
were together 42 years now, and we were
overseas traveling all the time, tired.
I said, you know, God gave me to you so
you'd be more like Jesus. Is that right?
Tell your spouse that. She'll like that.
[snorts]
Okay.
Number three, for thriving relationships
through prayer and other things. Assume
the best intentions about others motives
and actions. Wow. Greg had a problem. He
uh had planted a vegetable garden and he
had a bunch of slugs come and eat his
vegetables. You know what a slug is?
>> What is a slug?
>> Yeah. It's like a snail without a shell,
right? Okay. So, Greg is really upset
with that. So, he asked people, "How do
I get rid of these slugs in my vegetable
garden?" What do they What do you tell
what do they tell him? Salt.
>> Salt. What else?
>> Beer. Yeah. You drink beer, do you? No.
I Anyway. Yeah. Salt or beer. So Greg
says, "Okay." So he goes to the market
and he buys a six-ack of beer to kill
slugs. So he's coming to the checkout
counter and what happens?
Sure. He meets the head elder of the
church. They greet each other. They look
in the basket. Of course, the head elder
assumed Greg was buying beer for a good
purpose, right?
Wrong. Why do we always assume the worst
on the people around us so often?
We need to listen more. Seek first to
understand clearly and then to be
understood. Don't take things secondhand
from secondary sources. To go a little
slower. I need to do I I assume too
much. Um I I love what Doug was saying
this morning about communicating with
our spouses. My wife doesn't think I
listen very well. I think I'm a pretty
good listener, but
you know, I always know what she's going
to say, so I just try to cut to the
chase of fixing things for her. And yes,
sometimes she just wants to to tell me.
She wants to vent. She doesn't want me
to do anything. That's hard for an
administrator, you know. So anyway, but
we need to listen. Learn to listen.
Don't take things secondhand. And then
Ellen White says this. This Acts of
Apostles is the reference here. It
didn't get on the slide, but it's it's
Acts of the Apostles, page 319.
Christlike love places the most
favorable construction on the motives
and acts of others. Does not needlessly
expose their faults. It does not listen
eagerly to unfavorable reports but seeks
rather to bring to mind the good
qualities of others. My dad was a
wonderful uh farmer who became a
publishing director. Big smiling loving
guy. He was always defending my mom who
had depression and was pretty sharp with
people and caused trouble. But also one
day we had big blizzards in Colorado and
the public company didn't tell us for
almost two weeks what was going when it
was going to be fixed and this kind of
thing and we were all muttering about
the public's you know electrical
company. Dad says come on can you
imagine all the problems that they're
having right now and we said come on dad
nobody defends the utility companies but
that was my dad and I think God is
calling us to think the best on each
other best on the intentions of others.
Dad was always telling us, you know,
mom, what she says, don't listen to.
Listen to what she means. She loves you
and she's trying to do this or whatever.
Anyway, [snorts]
number four, principle number four for
thriving relationships. Follow Christ's
specific instructions and do not talk to
others about the problems. You always do
that. Yeah, we know Matthew 18, Matthew
15, um,
Ephesians 4 says, "Only say those things
which can be helpful for building others
up according to their needs. Even if
something is true, don't talk to others
about it if it can't help resolve the
problem. Wow. If it's true, I tend to
want to go and tell somebody. Maybe just
tell a few prayer partners about the
problem this person has. And then it
spreads. Self jumps up and it becomes a
bigger problem. The gospel order is what
we need to follow. Matthew 18. When a
brother in Christ sins against you,
what's the first step?
Go to that person alone. Why did Jesus
say that? Again, because of self. If we
start telling other people and explodes
bigger, what happens? that person has to
defend themselves, right? Because we've
we've made it into a big issue. If
needed, there really needs to be
changed. We can take one or two trusted
other people they may trust with us as
witnesses. Lastly, sometimes we have to
take it to the church for discipline.
But if we follow the instructions that
go Christ has given us, it'll make a big
difference. He said, even if people have
ought against you and you don't know why
he didn't do anything to them or
anything, still before you worship, seek
to be reconciled.
Um, and I before I go there, I'd just
like to say I found again if I spend
time with Jesus, even with people I
don't know why they're mad at me or why
we're separated, uh, he can often tell
me something that I can apologize to
them for. Maybe I didn't love them as
much as Jesus would have. Maybe I said
something a little bit too strong. I
don't know. But anyway, if I can if
Jesus can tell me something I can
apologize for, that will often break
down the barrier. may open up for them
to tell me more or them to even
apologize themselves. So anyway,
principle five, yield your rights and
expectations to God. Um, you know, when
we get married, we preach sermons, we
talk about agape love, we say, you know,
don't expect anything of your spouse.
Agape love is totally self-giving,
unconditional. No matter what they do to
you, you love it, right? How long does
that last?
We don't get home from the honeymoon,
right, from that one. But that's that's
the way we ought to be. Did Jesus ever
go around defending his own rights? No,
he did not go around defending his own
rights or getting angry. His
expectations weren't met. And many of
our relationship problems are when when
our expectations aren't met, right? In a
marriage, you didn't treat me the way
you should have. You didn't do this. You
didn't respect me as much as you should
have. But if we truly will have agape
love and put self aside, we'll be
willing unconditionally
to assume the best and to not get upset
so much. Great peace have they which
love thy law and nothing shall offend
them. Psalms 119 165. I like a couple of
things that Ty Gibson has said and I
think I'll share them with you at this
point about sharing our rights. He says
one of the strongest impulses of the
immature mind is to be right and set out
to prove it
that our marriage many times. Spiritual
adulthood, by contrast, is characterized
by a desire to understand and be
understood, attended by a keen sense
that I may be wrong.
How's that for a good relationship tip,
huh? I like another one. He said, "When
someone criticizes you, how do you
handle that? When someone criticizes
you, accuses you, or gossips about you,
maybe respond like this. That's nothing.
I've done worse than that.
What you've said about me isn't true,
but other things about me, as bad or
worse, are true. I survive against
myself by God's grace.
I like that. Lord, help us in our
relationships to be of one accord. Our
marriages could be so much better if we
put self aside and quit worrying about
who's right, who did what, who said what
to whom. I uh was teaching in New
Zealand of the union there, Pacific
Islands and New Zealand and I I shared
this presentation and there was a
pastoral it was pastors and their wives
and the next day this couple came to me
in fact they stood up and made a
testimony in the meeting. And they said,
"We were listening to what you said,
these these things from God, Bible and
spirit prophecy about being in one
accord and putting self aside." And we
looked at each other. We said, "We need
to talk." Said, "We went back to our
room that night, and in our room, we
started apologizing to each other for
all the things we've been offended
about, all the things we'd held against
them, and things we were so sure we were
right about." She said, "It was
wonderful." He said, "It's wonderful. We
were able to hug, embrace, and be of one
accord like we'd never been." They came
to tell the whole pastor's meeting what
could happen. Yeah. Five minutes can
remove most difficulties if we're
willing to put self aside in our
marriages. We can't always be run over.
I know there's a time for tough love
when abuse is going on or something like
that, but how much we could do. There is
a time for tough love. I'm not talking
about women being physically abused and
just putting up with that. There's
there's there barriers, but there's so
many things that are so little don't
matter. Jan and I so often now say it
doesn't matter. This is something we
could argue over who said what 10 years
ago and we get all frothed up about it.
Now we say it doesn't matter. And when
we do really want to find out, we've
made a deal to meet in the the video
room in the millennium and we'll see who
was right.
Yeah. Okay. We're moving to the end
here, but number six is to praise God
for the person who is the source of
irritation. That's a tough one. Um, make
a list. I'm going to rush here. Make a
list of the good things about the
person. Then praise God for those
things. Wow, that's a tough one, huh?
Janet had a real problem with this woman
who been very mean to her and think she
God told her to to make a list, but she
said, "I can't think of anything." I
said, "Well, she's not an axe murderer,
right? You can start with something like
that.
Pray for the problem person to be
blessed." That's tough. But it changes
us. Praise drives away evil angels. By
beholding, we become changed. If we
focus on somebody else's problem or what
they've done to us, it gets bigger in us
and we tend to carry out that same
activity. Are they going to hurt us with
that? I don't think so. Okay. And I love
this picture. Uh Ellen White says, "If
things are going crossways in your home,
there's a bad mood in the morning or
something." She says, "Um, break up
break into the doxology. Start singing a
praise song." So, I see this husband's
trying that.
You think that work very well? I don't
know. But the prophet said it would. Try
it. I think if we put praise music on,
though, if our house is filled with
praise, we're going to find some good
things happening.
Okay. Um, choose to lay aside your pride
and selfishness.
That's that's what we're saying is so
hard, right? And it is. Listen to this
vision that Ellen White had. She said,
"I saw." You know what that means?
[snorts] I'm sorry. This got in there
again. Pride and selfishness were laid
aside. Five minutes would remove those
difficulties. Do you know where that
came from? That came from an angel's
mouth in a vision.
Here it is. I saw that the remnant were
not prepared for what's coming on the
earth. Stupidity like lethargy seemed to
hang upon the minds of most of those who
profess to believe. We have the last
message. My accompanying angel cried out
with awful semnity. Get ready. Get
ready. For the fierce anger of the Lord
is soon to come. His wrath is to be
poured out unmixed with mercy and you're
not ready. Ren the heart and not the
garment. Great work must be done for the
remnant. Many of them are dwelling upon
little trials, said the angel. Legions
of evil angels are around you are trying
to press in their awful darkness that
you may be ens snared and taken. You
suffer your minds to be diverted too
readily from the work of preparation and
the allimportant truths for these last
days. And you dwell upon little trials,
go into minute particulars or little
difficulties to explain them to the
satisfaction of this one or that. Is
that true? Conversations
been protracted for hours between the
parties concerned. And not only has
their time been wasted, but the servants
of God are held to listen to them. And
the hearts of both parties are unsubdued
by grace. As a president, I can give
testimony. As a pastor, so often we're
arguing over justifying oursel, who did
what to whom. We get people on our side,
people on the other side. How does the
Lord feel about that? If pride and
selfishness were laid aside, she says,
five minutes would remove most
difficulties. Angels have been grieved
and God displeased by the hours which
have been spent in justifying ourselves.
I saw that God will not bow down and
listen to long justifications. And he
does not want his servants to do so
either. And thus precious time be wasted
that should be spent in showing
transgressors the errors of their ways
and pulling souls out of the fire. Wow.
That pretty strong stuff, isn't it?
Early writings 119
and 120. Um, that's from God himself
through an angel to Ellen White saying,
"Let's let this stuff go. Let's put
aside self." But, you know, it's really
difficult, isn't it? Um,
these seven things are really easy that
I've brought up, aren't they? Pray and
wait and listen instead of trying to
change others. Respect differences in
temperaments. Assume the best about
others motives and actions. Follow all
of God's specific instructions about
relationships. Yield all our rights and
expectations to Jesus and his cross.
Praise God for the source of our
irritations. And then five minutes if
pride and self were laid aside. It's too
hard, isn't it?
I'm supposed to be giving you happy,
joyful news here. How to have thriving
relationships and be happy and joyful.
Well, in these last several minutes, I'm
going to get to the the bottom line. I'm
out of time, but it's all right. Got to
go through this contemporary Peter. This
is a dialogue between a woman and God in
prayer. She says, "Lord, do you require
more of men than what I'm now doing? I'm
busy in your work, yet I'm not certain
that it's what you have for me to do.
Lord, what more can I do to serve you
better?" Lord says, "Nothing, my child."
But Lord, why do I feel discontented
with my service for you? I'm giving of
myself and my money unsparingly. I'm a
church deaconist and a Sabbath school
teacher. I give much of my time to
witnessing for you. What more can I do
for you? Nothing, my child. But Lord,
there still remains a vacancy inside in
spite of my private and public devotion
to you. What more can I do? Nothing.
Listen, my child, stop doing things for
me. Now, Lord, let's be reasonable.
You've blessed my work. You've exorted
me to labor in your vineyard. What do
you mean? What if I do stop doing things
for you? Then I'll be able to do them
through you. Oh, I think I see. Of
course, Lord. My work for you is in vain
unless you do it through me. Make me a
fit channel, Lord. Do humble me and may
I be a worthy vessel for you to use.
Now, what task do you want to do through
me?
None, my child. You [snorts] said you'd
work through me. What's your task for
me, my daughter? Love me.
Now, wait a minute, Lord. I've been a
Christian 11 years. What do you mean
love me? I do love you. Now, that's
settled. What's the next step?
There is no other step, loved one. Just
love me.
You know I love you, Lord. Why? My whole
life is taken up with service to you.
What do you mean?
Your love for me is revealed in your
love to your fellow men. Oh, I know
that, Lord. I do love my fellow men.
Do you love your biology professor?
Well, I don't I don't hate the guy. I
just leave him alone. He leaves me
alone.
Do you love your biology professor?
Now, look, we just don't get along. Our
personalities class, you know, you can't
solve that. So, I just avoid him.
I died for him and I live for him, too.
Oh, I know, Lord. And you know, I'd like
to see him save, but you understand that
I don't just I just don't click with
him.
Do you love your biology professor?
I respect him. I think he respects me. I
recognize he's a fine fellow. And I'm
sure he'd make a good Christian, but I
guess I do think of him as being well
overconfident, conceited, even a bigot
at times. You know, he's kind, Lord. Why
all this about him, Lord? Look at all
these other people I love. Boy, I could
Do you love your biology professor?
Well, he's the one person, Lord, that I
just can't stand. He's pretty hard to
take. But I do love, I guess, everyone
else. And certainly, you know, I love
you.
You only love me to the extent that you
love the person you like the least.
You only love me to the extent you love
the person you like the least.
>> [snorts]
>> But well then I I really don't care
about you then. But I've been a
Christian 11 years. I always thought I
loved you. Now I see. Lord, thank you
for revealing this to me. I will truly
love you now. You cannot, my child.
But you said love me. And when I said
okay, you I don't understand.
How can you love me? There's no love in
you. God is love.
And I can't love anyone.
No. Oh, you're only the channel through
which I can love anyone.
Then love this world through me, Lord.
This world of broken men. You love
through Lord through death, Lord. Love
through me again. Yes, my child, I will.
Is that too strong?
We only love God to the extent that we
love the person we like the least. What
did Jesus say? Assurely I say to you, in
as much as you did it to one of the
least of these, my brethren, you did it
to me.
Thank God. He says in Romans 5:5, "The
love of God is shed or brought in our
hearts by the Holy Spirit which is given
to us." It's a gift. But we have to ask.
Ask and we shall receive. We cannot love
each other. We can't be of one accord.
We can't have thriving relationships. We
can't get rid of these seven things
unless we constantly are asking Jesus to
abide in us and us to abide in him.
Philippians 4:13-19, I can do all things
through Christ who strengthens me, and
my God shall supply all your need
according to his riches and glory by
Christ Jesus. All his biddings are
enablings, right? When he commands
something, he gives us the strength to
do it. I pray for you that you'll have
thriving relationships with your
marriage, your kids, your family.
Apologies may need to happen. We may
need to spend enough time with God that
we humble ourselves to the point where
we can actually take blame for some of
the things that happened. some of the
things that can bear break down those
barriers in the past. But I want now to
share with you the really positive news.
This is a te a statement that I quote
quite often anymore in my morning prayer
time with Jesus. Christ object lessons.
Ellen White says, "No observances can
take the place of simple faith and
entire renunciation of self." But look
at this what she says. But no man can
empty himself of self.
That's the prophet saying that we can't
do it. We cannot do it. It's just not in
us. We're so carnal, so selfish. But she
goes on. She says, "We can only consent
for Christ to accomplish the work." Then
the language of the soul will be, and
here's a prayer I hope you mark down.
It's on the back inside back cover of
this booklet you're going to get, but
you've got it on your your hand out
there in the back. She gives us a
prayer. And this prayer is so
encouraging to me. She says, "The prayer
of your soul will be Lord, take my
heart, for I cannot give it.
It is your property." In other words,
we've already given our heart to him.
But today, I have a lot of trouble
surrendering totally and giving him my
heart. So, she says, "Be honest with
him. I cannot give it. It's your
property. Keep it pure, for I cannot
keep it pure for you men, but all of us.
Save me in spite of myself, my weak and
Christlike self." Hallelujah. Mold me,
fashion me, raise me into a pure and
holy atmosphere where the rich current
of thy love can flow through my soul.
The prophet's given us a prayer for this
problem of getting rid of self, this
problem of having a pure heart. This
problem of being what Jesus wants us to
be. We can't do it. And if we try to
tell him we can, we're fooling
ourselves. Now, it doesn't mean we won't
cooperate. We have to work, too. We have
to be with him. But we have to consent
because only Jesus can accomplish that
work in us. Isn't that good news? Amen.
That's the righteousness of Christ. I
say again, desire of ages 668. He will
come in and so work in our heart that
our wills can be molded and changed to
the point where when we're doing his
will and what he wants, we'll just be
doing what we wanted to do anyway. I
pray for that. I pray for it for you. Uh
we've had enough traveled around the
world and people are always telling
everybody what they ought to do, what we
ought to be. This is what we ought to
do. But I tell you what, I watch the
people in every culture go, "I've tried.
It's not working." I think it's time we
say, "God has a character that gives us
the ability to do what he's asked us to
do. Don't just tell me to be good. Don't
tell me to get rid of self. Don't tell
me to give up sin, all these things. I
can't without Jesus. I can give him
consent, but he's got to come in and
make me willing, willing to be made
willing.
>> Then we can do it." And that's good
news. That is joy. When we put Jesus in
charge of getting self out of us, then
we're going to find the happiness come.
Let's pray together for a minute. And as
we close in silent prayer, I would hope
you'd maybe heard the Holy Spirit
speaking to you about a person or
somebody that you need to be reconciled
with or maybe something else. Maybe it's
all about time with him better than
you've been spending. But let's just
talk to Jesus and ask for help in those
areas. And if we need to make
reconciliation with somebody that we're
totally apart, Janet's bitterness kept
her from having a thriving relationship
for years, uh, just tell him you want
him to work on it to help you get that
done as soon as possible. But just pray
silently, whatever you need to respond
to Jesus before I'm finished.
>> [snorts]
>> Thank you, Lord Jesus. Thank you,
Father. Spirit, change us. Make us that
church that can have Ezekiel 37 happen
after you give us the new hearts of
Ezekiel 36. And we'll see the latter
rain happening, the breath of the spirit
poured out, the church raising up like a
mighty army. We need you. use us and
bless this group. Lord, I pray you'll
pour your spirit upon them in a mighty
way in Jesus name. Amen.
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Marada,
>> Christ is coming. Amen.
>> And so we want to thank you and welcome
everybody that's here in person at the
Granite Bay Hilltop SDA Church. Welcome
to our teach us to pray pray prayer
summit. Those that are watching online
amazing facts TV social media. We have
been rejoicing and studying the word and
drawing closer uh to the Lord through
the prayer the blessing that we have to
talk with the Lord. How many of you have
been blessed so far? Amen. And so just a
reminder we have uh this next session
coming up with uh Pastor Randy Ski and
then we're going to have a Q&A. So, if
you want to have a question regarding
anything that has been spoken about
during this series, there's the QR code.
If you are watching online or if you're
here in person, you can scan that QR
code and you can submit your question
and we will try to answer that question
as best as possible uh during the
session after this next presentation.
Also, I want to remind you about our
free offer. It's the booklet, Teach Us
to Pray by Pastor Doug Bachelor. You can
receive this free gift with the QR code
that you see on the screen there, a
digital copy. If you are in the United
States of America, you can text pray 26
to number 40544
and you will receive that gift. Another
reminder, remember we have the
technology of AI which is translating
all of this content into multiple
languages. You can also scan that QR
code so you can receive uh the link to
where you can listen to this programming
in different languages. And one more
announcement we have for tomorrow
morning, remember tomorrow morning at
9:00 we're going to have a morning
prayer workshop. So it's going to be a
little bit more dynamic, interactive,
and you will receive if you come
tomorrow morning a special prayer
journal from Amazing Facts to help you
and start off with this new year
reignited with your prayer life. That
said, we're going to have next pastor
Randy Ski. Uh you all we've heard a
pastor, minister, international speaker
and uh inspiring us to draw closer to
the Lord of God through prayer. Before
he comes out, I'd like to have a word of
prayer to bless this next program. Oh,
let me pray for the pastor.
Father, thank you for the blessing and
the privilege that you have given us of
being here today. And as we uh again
come to listen to your word, as we want
to draw closer to you, we ask a special
blessing. Anoint the mind and the lips
of Pastor Ski that you can speak in him
and you can speak through him so that we
can all see the wonder and and and
gracious loving father that you are and
we can draw closer to you to Christ the
spirit through your word. We thank you
in Jesus precious name. Amen.
After this, there was a feast of the
Jews, and Jesus went up to Jerusalem.
[clears throat] Now there is at
Jerusalem by the sheep market a pool,
which is called in the Hebrew tongue
Bethesda, having five porches. In these
lay a great multitude of impotent folk,
a blind halt withered, waiting for the
moving of the water. For an angel went
down at a certain season into the pool,
and troubled the water. Whosoever then
first after the troubling of the water
stepped in, was made whole of whatsoever
disease he had. And a certain man was
there which had an infirmity 30 and8
years. When Jesus saw him lie, and knew
he had been now a long time in that
case, he said unto him, Wil thou be made
whole.
The imminent man answered to him, "Sir,
I have no man when the water is troubled
to put me into the pool, but while I'm
coming, another stepeth down before me."
Jesus said unto him, "Rise,
take up thy bed, and walk." And
immediately the man was made whole, and
took up his bed and walked. And on the
same day was the Sabbath. The Jews
therefore said unto him that was cured,
it is the Sabbath day, it is not lawful
for thee to carry thy bed. He answered
them, he that made me whole, the same
said unto me, Take up thy bed and walk.
Then asked they him, what man is that
which said unto thee, Take up thy bed
and walk? And he that was healed wish
not who it was? For Jesus had conveyed
himself away, a multitude being in that
place. Afterward Jesus findeth him in
the temple, and said unto him, Behold,
thou art made whole.
Sin no more, lest a worse thing come
unto thee. sin no more, lest a worse
thing come unto thee.
God is good
>> all the time
>> and all the time.
>> Psalm 100 verse5. For the Lord is good.
His mercy is everlasting
and his truth endureth to all
generations.
>> Amen. And I frequently say truth will
endure to all generations.
But one day error will come to an end
along with those who persist in living
their lives by error.
I feel compelled to say it again.
One day
error, false doctrine will come to an
end along with those who persist
>> in living their lives by in other words,
you know the Bible says this, but you
choose to do that because your friends
are doing that.
>> You know the Bible says this, but you
choose to do that because it's more
popular. You know the Bible says this,
but you choose that because it's more
convenient. Let me tell you something.
The fires of hell will not be
convenient.
So much for that.
How are you?
>> You look like nice people.
>> Yeah, you do. I like you.
>> Would somebody say amen?
I like you.
>> And when the service ends, I'll
determine whether or not I love you. But
I like you to start.
>> As I see how you respond and you say
amen, then I'll decide to love you. But
right now, I like you very much. Is that
okay? We must grow in grace. Are you
with me? All right. Is there anyone
present now? You were not here last
night or this morning. Can I see your
hand?
>> God bless you. God bless you. Blue is
the color of obedience in the Bible.
Very nice. Anybody else? You were not
here this morning or last night. You are
here tonight. Today. God bless you. God
bless you. I mean that. Now, is there
anyone with us now? You were not here
last night or this morning. You are here
for the first time. You are not a
Seventh Day Adventist. You're here this
afternoon for the first time. May I see
your hand?
Ah, God bless you. Mhm. Anybody else?
You're not an Adventist. You are here
for the very first time. May I see your
hand? Okay, we have a hand over here, a
hand over there. They're light in my
eyes. I don't see anyone in the balcony.
All right, let me offer a prayer for
those of you who are guests for the
first time. Father, I come to you today.
God, seriously, we have two or three
guests first time this weekend. I ask
you God very directly because you're God
of mercy and love and generosity.
Bless them to such a degree they will
always remember the time spent with us.
Bless them to such a degree, Father,
that they will know beyond any doubt
that divinity has moved in their lives.
Bless them their God to such a degree
that they become a blessing wherever
they go. Heal their diseases, provide
their needs, remove their enemies,
Father, and save them when you come. In
the name of Jesus Christ, I pray. Let
God's people say, "Amen." And amen. And
that prayer covered all our guests
online.
I want to do something. I will do
something
consistent with the passage I read at
the beginning.
Before I do it, let me ask you to help
me. Name some very serious diseases or
illnesses that we dread. Name them.
>> Cancer. Another one.
>> Hi.
>> Alzheimer's. Go on.
>> Diabetes.
>> Diabetes. Go on.
>> Heart condition. Mhm.
>> Parkinson's. Heart condition.
>> Autoimmune diseases.
>> Serious illnesses. Anymore?
Say it again.
>> HIV.
>> HIV. I'll repeat it for the sake of the
online audience.
>> What's that?
>> Multiple sclerosis.
>> Lupus,
>> schizophrenia,
>> leric disease,
>> chronic depression.
What's that?
>> COPD.
>> What's that? Chronic obstructive.
Whatever. All right.
>> Now, what?
>> Chronic pulmonary obstructive
>> diseases have fancy names. Okay. Now,
listen carefully. Listen carefully.
>> If you are suffering from any one of
these things, I want to pray for you.
Come.
It's all right to stand and preach, but
sometimes you need to directly deal with
what people are suffering with. If
you're afflicted with any of the things
we named, come
if you can. We're going to kneel and
pray.
Come.
If you're online, kneel where you are.
The rest of you, you should be praying.
Not just watching, praying.
Anybody else keep coming?
I should tell you this is very serious
moment.
I felt an impression from God to offer
this prayer. Let me tell you immediately
I have no power.
None. But I'll talk to God who has
power. Can you say amen?
>> But I have none.
Before
I pray,
let me read some Bible passages for you.
If thou will diligently hearken unto the
voice of the Lord thy God, one word for
that is obey.
And will do that which is right in his
sight, one word for that is obey. And
will give ear to his commandments, one
word for that, obey.
and keep all his statutes. One word for
that, obey. I will put none of these
diseases upon you, which I have put upon
the Egyptians
if you will obey.
Exodus 23:2,
"And ye shall serve the Lord your God,
and he shall bless thy bread and thy
water, and the Lord shall take sickness
away from the midst of thee." The verse
begin, thou shalt serve. To serve God is
to obey.
Psalm 103:3,
who forgiveth all thine iniquities,
which means who forgives our
disobedience, then who healeth all our
diseases. I want to make a clear
connection between sickness and sin.
James 5 14-16.
Is any sick among you? Let him call for
the elders of the church, and let them
pray over him, anointing him with all in
the name of the Lord, and the prayer of
faith shall save the sick, and the Lord
shall raise him up, and if he have
committed sins, they shall be forgiven
him. We've read four texts. And there's
a connection between sickness and sin.
It may not be sins you have committed.
It may simply be living in a sinful
world.
And so while I pray for you, ask God to
forgive you for any sins you've
committed. Any means of offense against
God, ask him to forgive you.
I'll give you 30 seconds to do that now.
Then I'll pray. You pray now for your
forgiveness right now.
Dear God,
gathered before you are those who are
sick,
afflicted,
suffering from one ailment or another.
Father, I read the passage in John five.
In these lay a great multitude of
impotent folk. Father, there was a great
multitude of sick. Yet Jesus healed one
man.
I want everyone kneeling in your
presence to believe. He or she is that
one person
>> upon whom God father you may place your
healing hand.
If I've offended you today, God forgive
me. Please.
And father, as I pray for those whom you
love, help them to understand the power
lies with you, not me.
As Peter and John said to the man whom
they healed who was lame.
In the name of Jesus Christ, their God,
have mercy on the sick.
Father, we're tired of sickness.
We're tired of doctor's visits. We're
tired of days lost to work. We're tired
of being stuck in a bed. We are tired of
sickness, Father.
And I ask you now in the name of Jesus
Christ, if it pleases you, but remember
your God of mercy, touch the sick, dear
God. There is no sickness that can
withstand your power. Because if you can
forgive sin, which is the worst kind of
sickness, surely you can cleanse someone
from hypertension or cancer. But as I
pray to you, God to heal them. Father,
you show them what they can do to change
their health habits and their behavior
and their conduct so that they may
cooperate with you in their healing and
their restoration.
Father,
Jesus healed many people. Some he healed
immediately, others they were healed
after a while. When the 10 lepers came
to him, he said, "Go show yourselves
unto the priests." Your word says, "As
they went, they were healed." In other
words, as they obeyed, they were healed.
They were not healed immediately.
The man who was blind, he recovered his
sight gradually. He saw men as trees
until he finally received sight. Father,
you choose how you will do it. But
please God remind us of how powerful you
are by bring healing upon somebody
even as the person kneels right now. Do
something God.
Father
there are those online. I'm praying for
them who are sick. Please God have mercy
upon us. Heal someone.
If you will not heal, bring tremendous
relief. A relief that comes across as
miraculous.
Father, we'll give you the praise, the
honor, and the glory.
And as I bring this prayer to a close,
dear God, remind those whom you love
to get sin out of their lives,
>> please, for the highest healing, which
is spiritual.
Now, Father, one more time, at the risk
of irritating you, I ask you again, do
something for someone with a serious
illness. Dear God, that he or she might
have a testimony that God is still good.
Do that, Father. I pray in Jesus name.
Let God's people say, "Amen." And amen.
Let's sing one stanza of To God be the
glory. Great things he have done. To God
be the glory. Great things he had done.
So love he the world that he gave us his
[singing] son.
who yield in his life and atonement for
sin
and open the life [singing] gate that
all may go. Praise the Lord. Praise the
[singing] Lord. Praise the [music] Lord.
Let the earth give [singing] his voice.
Praise the Lord. Praise the Lord. Let
the people rejoice.
Oh, come to the [singing] Father through
Jesus the Son
and give him the glory.
[singing and music]
Great things he have done. [singing]
>> God is good
>> all the time
>> and all the time.
>> God is good.
>> How many of you love God? Amen.
>> On the count of three, we'll say,
"Father, we love you." We'll say it
three times. 1 2 3. Father, we love you.
One more time. Father, we love you. One
more time. Father, we love you. Now,
three times we'll make it personal
>> and I'll see if you understand what I'm
saying. One, two, three. Father, I love
you. Come on. Father, I love you.
Father, I love you because you first
loved me.
>> No one can love God unless the person
understands that God first loved him or
her.
>> Amen.
>> Our subject for today when in France
speak French.
>> What did I say?
>> In France.
>> What was our subject last night? This
side. Too slow. That side.
>> Too slow. That side.
Nobody got it. I'm all his.
>> What was our subject this morning over
here?
>> What's our subject today?
>> When in France speak French.
Before we get into that and I was told I
have all the time I need,
but I believe in temperance even in
preaching.
Do you have one of these?
Why didn't you answer me?
>> Do you have one of these?
>> Yes.
>> Do you need it as a Bible?
>> Okay, you can use yours on.
>> Thank you.
>> The rest of you, turn them off.
>> I'm waiting for you to turn them off. Go
ahead.
>> Don't look at me. Turn them off.
>> Say that again.
>> Sister God bless you.
May God bless you more than he blesses
me. Hers is at home.
>> Mhm.
>> Are they off now?
>> Say amen for obedience.
>> Some of you said amen, but you didn't
turn them off.
All right. Favor number two. While I'm
speaking, pray for me and say what?
Lord, come on. Put your words in that
man's mouth. I am not joking.
who has not yet offered that prayer for
me. Can I see your guilty hands?
You've not yet prayed for me. Where are
you? Ah, you're still a nice person. God
bless you. But pray.
What will you say, Lord? Put your words
in that man's mouth. That's based on
Jeremiah 1:9, which says, "Then the Lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth.
And the Lord said unto me, Behold, I
have put my words in thy mouth." When
God puts his words in your mouth, keep
your opinions to yourself,
and just give the people, "Thus saith
the Lord."
>> Amen.
>> Favor number three, think as you listen.
Isaiah 1:18. Come now, let us do what?
Reason together, say the Lord.
Father,
speak through me
clearly, directly.
I step out of the way.
Do with me what you will. Bless your
people with truth. Those in this
building and those online. In the name
of Jesus Christ, I pray. Amen.
>> Go to Genesis chapter 1. We'll read from
verse one. Our subject, when in France,
speak French. And I always keep in mind
our emphasis is prayer. I haven't
forgotten that.
Do you have Genesis 11
reading from verse one?
>> When you found it, say amen.
>> Amen. [clears throat]
>> Read with me. And the whole earth was of
one language of one speech. It came to
pass as they journeyed from the east
that they found a plain in the land of
Shina and they dwelt there. And they
said one to another, "Go to let us make
brick and burn them thoroughly." So they
had brick for stone, and slime had there
for mortar. And they said, "Go to, let
us build us a city and a tower, whose
top may reach unto heaven. And let us
make us a name, lest we be scattered
abroad upon the face of the whole
earth." And the Lord came down to see
the seat in the tower which the children
of men buildth. And the Lord said,
"Behold, the people is one and have all
one language. And this they begin to do,
and now nothing will be restrained from
them which they have imagined to do." Go
to let us go down and do what?
Confound their languages. Why? That they
may not understand. Come on, one
another's feet.
All these languages we have of which
we're so proud,
that's the result of sin.
There are wars fought
because of a language differences.
From time to time, the province of
Quebec in Canada, hello Quebec,
agitate to be independent from the rest
of the country because it has a
different language and culture which is
French. In the beautiful country of
Spain, there's an area called the Basque
country. They have a slightly different
language. From time to time they agitate
to be separate and it has led to
hostilities. The same thing in Ethiopia
and other parts of the world. Language
differences cause problems.
Before language differences, I should
say are the result of sin.
What's our subject?
>> In France.
>> When in France
>> speak French. We need to understand what
is the language of
>> God. Not friends. God.
>> Well, you can't blame her. That's the
subject.
What is the language of God? Now, let's
reason through the scriptures. You know,
I love the Bible. Say amen.
>> Amen.
If you take time for this and ask God to
help you,
you will discover things that will
change your lives.
>> Amen.
>> You'll develop a hatred for sin and a
love for righteousness.
>> Amen.
>> Guaranteed.
>> Let's go to 2 Chronicles chapter 20.
We'll read from verse four.
2 Chronicles chapter 20 reading from
verse 4. Let me set it up. Three armies
are threatening Jerusalem or Judah.
Jehoshaphat is told that these three
armies are threatening to attack
Jerusalem.
Jehoshaphat calls all the people
together to pray. Verse four. And Judah
gathered themselves together to ask help
of the Lord, even out of all the cities
of Judah. They came to seek the Lord.
And Jehoshaphat stood in the
congregation of Judah and Jerusalem
in the court of the Lord in the temple
of the Lord before the new court and
said, read with me now. Oh Lord, come
on. God of our fathers. That's one
statement. Art not thou God in heaven
and rulest not thou over all the
kingdoms of the heathen? Now we can
pause right there. The first thing he
says is, "Oh Lord our God, art not thou
God in heaven?" Question for you. Is God
in heaven?
>> Amen.
>> Why didn't more of you say yes?
Is God in heaven?
>> Yes. Say the Lord's prayer. Our father.
>> When Jehoshaphat said, "Oh Lord, God of
our fathers, art not thou God in
heaven?" When he said that, did he say
something that is biblically correct?
>> Yes.
And rulest not thou over all the
kingdoms of the heathen?
>> Is that biblically true? Yes.
>> Go to Psalm 47.
Our subject, when in France, speak
French. My friends online, stay with us,
please.
Do you have Psalm 47?
>> You read verse 8. Read it nice and loud.
What does that say? God, come on.
Reignth where? Over the heathen.
Jehoshaphat said, "Art not thou and
rulest not thou over all the kingdom of
the heathen?" When Jehoshaphat said
that, was he saying something biblical?
Yes.
And in thine hand is not their power and
might so that none is able to withstand
thee. Let's go to the Bible. Go to 1
Chronicles chapter 29. We read from
verse 11.
Now I'll go back from 1 Chronicles to 2
Chronicles. So we make the connection.
Keep both passages ready and available.
Do you have 1 Chronicles 29:11?
>> Hold on to it. Go back to 2 Chronicles
20 verse 6.
>> Amen.
>> Now, do you see? And in thine hand is
not their power and might so that none
is able to withstand thee. Do you see
that?
>> Good. Now, keep this in mind. Let's go
now to 1 chronicle to 1st Chronicles 29
11. Let's read from verse 12, not 11:12.
Both riches and honor come of thee, and
thou reignest over all. Read with me
now. And in thine hand is power and
might.
Now,
let's go back to 2 Chronicles uh 20:6.
And in thy hand is not their power and
might. So that none is able to withstand
thee. When Jehoshaphat said that, was he
saying something biblical?
>> Yes, it's in the scriptures.
Verse seven, what does that say?
>> Art not thou our God, which is drive out
the inhabitants of this land before thy
people Israel, and givest it to the seed
of Abraham, thy friend forever?
Let's go to Genesis 13.
We read from verse 14. When I go too
quickly, just say, "Slow down, please."
Thank you. I really mean that. When I
get excited, I go too quickly. Elise
said, "Speak slowly and don't shout."
That's what she said. No, no. She said,
"Don't shout." She said, "What does all
this shouting do?" That's what she
wrote. All this, she calls it hallowing.
Why are you shouting? Don't shout.
I'll try not to shout.
What book did I send you to?
>> What chapter?
>> Reading from verse 14.
>> Well, let me shout a little bit. Verse
14. Do you have that?
>> Read with me. And the Lord said unto
Abram, after that Lot was separated from
him, lift up not thine eyes, and look
from the place where thou art. Come on.
Northward and southward and eastward and
westward. For all the land which thou
see it, to thee will I give it, come on,
and to thy seed, come on, forever. To
thee will I give it, and to thy seed
forever. Go back to 2 Chronicles 20.
Let's read verse 7. What's our subject?
>> You have 2 Chronicles 20:7.
>> Read for me. What does that say? Art not
our God which has drive out the
inhabitants of this land before thy
people Israel and gavest it to the seed
of Abraham thy friend forever. When
Jehoshaphat said that, was he saying
something biblical? Yes.
Now
let's go to Acts chapter 4, the book of
Acts, New Testament chapter 4. We read
from verse 23. Our subject when in
France speak French.
Do you have the book of Acts?
>> Who wrote the book of Acts?
>> Luke.
>> Luke. Very good. What other book did
Luke write?
>> Luke.
He started to pray. What book did he
write? Okay. Luke.
>> All right. Okay. What chapter did I say?
>> What verse?
>> Let me set it up for you. Peter and
John, you know, they'd healed the man,
you know, who was lame. Now, the
Sanhesian were upset. They called them
in, told him, "Stop this." And but they
could not deny the miracle that was
done. And so they threatened them and
let them go. Verse 23, read with me. And
being let go, they went what? They did
what? Returned to their own company and
reported all that the chief priests and
elders had said unto them. And when they
come on had heard that, they lifted
their voices to God with one accord and
said, "What?"
>> Oh Lord, come on.
>> Stop.
>> What do they say?
>> Lord,
>> thou art God.
>> Without you without going to Bible text.
Come on. Is that biblical?
>> Yes. They're praying.
>> Lord, thou art God. Keep reading. which
has made heaven and the earth and the
sea and all that in them is next verse.
Who by the mouth of thy servant David
has said, why did the heathen rage and
the people imagine vain things? Go to
Psalm two.
You're not telling me to slow down. It's
your fault.
>> Tell me slow or just do that.
I need to slow down. Slow down.
>> Thank you again after the fact. Okay. Do
you have the book of Psalms,
>> chapter 2,
>> reading from verse one. But before you
read verse one, keep your finger on
Psalm 2. Don't lose it. Go back to Acts
4.
Keep your finger on Psalm two. You have
10 fingers. What's the problem? Keep
your finger on Psalm two and go back to
Acts chapter 4.
You have it.
>> What does verse 25 say?
>> Who by the mouth come on
>> of thy servant David have said what? Why
did the heathen rage and the people
imagine vain faith? Listen now. Why did
the heathen rage and the people imagine
vain faith? They are praying. Now let's
go to Psalm two. We read from verse one
nice and loud. What does that say? Why
do the heathen rage and the people
imagine a vain things? The kings if they
have set themselves and the rulers took
counsel together against the Lord and
against his anointed saying, "Let us
break their bands of sand and cast away
the cords from us." Those disciples in
the book of Acts chapter 4. They were
praying and they were quoting what?
Scripture.
Tell me, slow down, please.
You're so attractively stubborn. And I
ask you to tell me slow down.
Now, what's our subject?
>> When in Spain,
>> when in Mexico
>> when in Russia, speak Russia.
>> When in Ethiopia, speak the dominant
language. When in Kenya, speak Swahili.
When in Granite Bay, speak English.
Is that okay? Now
what is the language of God?
>> Ah who said that
>> word
>> I heard someone over here
>> his word
>> is his language.
>> Now Jehoshaphat is praying.
He uses a language God can
understand.
And so he says, "Lord God of our
fathers,"
God told Moses, Exodus 3:6, "Moreover,"
he said, "I am the God of thy father,
the God of Abraham, the God of Isaac,
the God of Jacob." God told that to
Jacob in Genesis 28.
Jehoshaphat is praying the language of
God.
And ruleest not thou over all the
kingdom of the heathen. Yes. The Bible
says that Jehoshaphat is using the
language of God.
>> Amen.
>> When in France,
>> speak French. When in the presence of
God,
>> that's his language.
>> Word.
>> The word.
And so when the disciples left the
Sanhedrin, Acts chapter 4 23, they went
to their own company that speak the same
language
>> and told him what had happened. They
lifted up their voices with one accord
to God and said, "Lord
God, biblical which has made heaven and
earth and the sea and all that in them
is biblical. Who by the mouth of thy
David, thy servant David have said, why
did the heathen rage biblical? And the
people imagine
>> vain things biblical.
>> Our emphasis this weekend, prayer.
Use God's language.
>> Amen.
>> Parents, your child has left the church.
Well, let's change that. Your child has
left Jesus.
>> Your heart is broken.
You send him to church school
from elementary all the way to Oakwood
or Lassier or Walawala or Andrew left
the church. You're embarrassed because
you feel guilty. Where did I fail?
Where did I fail? And you're praying for
your children.
Pray in God's language.
>> Amen.
>> What do I mean?
The Lord is not willing that
>> Jehoshaphat asked God some questions. He
said, "Art not thou God in heaven?" What
did God say?
>> Come on. Use your imagination. Come on.
>> Is God in heaven? Yes or no?
>> When Jehoshaphat said, "Art thou God in
heaven?" What did God say? Yes.
Yes.
>> Think
rulest thou not over all the kingdom of
the heathen? Does the Bible say that?
>> What did God say? Yes.
>> And in thy hand is not their power and
might so that none is able to withstand
thee. What did God say? Yes.
Art not thou our God which is drive out
the inhabitants of this land? What did
God say? Yes.
Pray so that God says yes.
way. Pray in such a way that as much as
possible, God says yes.
>> Amen.
>> There's a psychological principle. You
get someone saying yes long enough, it's
difficult for the person to say
>> no.
Nobody's listening.
>> I'm talking to myself.
>> Your child has left the church.
The Bible says, "The Lord is not slack
concerning his promises as some men come
slackness, but is longsuffering to
usward, not willing that any should
perish, but that all should come to
repentance." Now, you're praying for
your son. Let's say his name is
Sebastian.
>> You said, "Father,
did you not say you're not willing for
Sebastian to be lost?" What does God
say?
>> Yes.
He has to say yes because he cannot deny
his word.
>> We're not manipulating God. We're using
the word of God.
>> Now, when I say God can't deny his word,
go to second Timothy chapter 2. We'll
read from verse 11. What's our subject?
>> Let me pray again. Father, my friends
will not tell me to slow down. I don't
know why,
but I'm trying. Restrain me, God. I
really mean that. I want you to get the
glory, not me. Please, father, help me
to slow down.
Let me think of your glory only. I pray
in Jesus name. Amen.
>> What book did I say?
>> What chapter
>> from what verse?
>> 11. Read microscopically. I told you God
does not deny himself. I said that. Are
you ready?
>> What does that verse say? It
>> is a faithful saying. For if we be dead
with him, we shall also live with him.
If we suffer, we shall also reign with
him. If we deny him, we what?
>> He will deny us. Now verse 13. If we
what? Believe not, yet he abideth
faithful. Finish the verse. He cannot
deny himself. Now, Bible study requires
simple thinking. Look at 13 again. Read
it for me. If
Stop. If we don't believe,
but what are we called upon to believe?
Don't hesitate. What are we called upon
to believe?
>> The word.
If we believe not,
he abide the faithful. He cannot deny
himself. But what is himself?
>> Oh yes. Yes. Did you hear that assistant
preacher? Yes, it's the word.
>> John 14:6,
>> I am the way,
>> the truth. But what is truth? Sanctify
them to thy truth.
>> Now John 1:1, in the beginning was the
word. The word was with God. The word
was God. This is the word.
>> Revelation 19:13. And he was clothed
with a vesture dipped in blood. And his
name is called the word of God. When the
Bible says he cannot deny himself, he
cannot deny his word.
>> Amen.
>> You're getting me tired.
>> Are you following me?
>> He cannot deny his word. And so you
can't tell God what to do. I know that.
But he cannot deny his word.
>> Amen.
>> Go to John 11.
We read 11, not John 11, sorry. John 17,
11 and 12. My friends online, I hope
you're still with us, please. Even if
it's 4:00 in the morning, stay up and
listen to God's word.
>> Do you have John 17?
>> Father, continue to be with me. I pray.
Please, in the name of Jesus Christ, I
pray that all God's people say, "Amen."
And amen. John 17 11 and 12. When you're
there, say, "Amen."
>> Amen.
>> And now I am no more in the world, but
these are in the world, and I come to
thee. Holy Father, keep through thy
known name those whom thou has given me,
that they may be one, as we are. Now
listen to 12. While I was with them in
the world, I kept them in thy name.
Those thou thou givest me, I have kept,
and none of them is lost, but the son of
predition. Why? That the scripture might
be fulfilled.
>> The Bible said someone would betray
Christ.
Not even Christ could stop that from
being fulfilled.
>> Ah, you didn't hear me.
>> Did you hear me? Not even God can
prevent his word from being fulfilled.
Amen.
>> He said, "Those that thou gavest to me,
I have kept. None of them is lost, but I
couldn't keep him
because the Bible says someone would
betray me.
>> He cannot deny
>> himself."
>> Amen.
There are many of us perhaps sitting
right there and online. We carry guilt
even after we confess.
>> God hasn't forgiven me and we walk in a
hunchback of Notraam.
>> 1 John 1:9. Read with me. If we confess
our sin, you finish it.
>> Is that the word of God?
>> Amen.
>> Can God deny his word? No. When you
don't believe it, you call him a liar.
[crying]
>> What did I just say? When we do not
believe the word of God, we call him a
liar.
>> Go to First John chapter 5. You're
looking at me and saying, "Explain
that." Go to First John 5. We read verse
10.
Teach us to pray. Mhm. Part three.
Are you at First John
>> chapter 5?
>> Reading verse 10.
>> I ask you to read with me. I never hear
you, but anyway, I'll keep asking.
>> Amen.
>> You have to persist sometime. Are you
there?
>> Read with me. What does that say?
>> He that hath
>> son of God,
>> he that have the son of God, come on.
>> Hath the witness in himself. Keep
reading. He that believeth not, come on,
>> God. made him a liar.
>> Okay.
>> Why? Because he what?
>> The record that God gave of his son.
>> Read that verse again. He that hath the
son hath the witness, come on, in
himself. He that believeth not hath made
God
>> a liar.
Let me make it even worse. Go to John 8.
Don't Don't lose 1 John chapter 5. Don't
lose it. Remember I told you have 10
fingers. Keep one on first John 5. Use
another one to get John chapter 8. Let's
read verse 44. Our subject is what? When
in France speak French. When with God
speak his language. What's that? The
word.
>> Mhm.
>> What book did I say?
>> What chapter?
>> What verse? 44. You know it very well.
Ye are of your father the devil and the
lust of your father you will do. He was
a murderer from the beginning and abode
not in the truth because there is no
truth in him. When he speaketh a lie he
speaketh of his own or his own language
for he is a liar
>> and the father of it. Now the Bible says
Satan is a liar. Amen.
>> First John 5:10 says, "When we don't
believe God's word, we make God a liar."
>> Here's one of the tricks of the devil.
He gets us to believe that his satanic
characteristics are the characteristics
of God.
>> The devil tries to get us to believe
that God is harsh, unyielding, severe,
cold, callous. He gets people to believe
that about God, but that's how he is.
>> And so when we don't believe, the Bible
says you're making God a liar,
which is effectively calling God Satan.
Because Jesus said the liar is Satan.
This is serious business. That's why
without faith, come on, it's impossible.
What's our subject?
>> What's the language of God?
>> Word.
>> Now, let me ask you this. Quiz time.
Don't give me a wrong answer.
We're on the internet. People are
listening to you and watching you. Do
not embarrass this church. Are you with
me?
>> All right.
Did Jehoshaphat quote scripture?
>> Yes.
>> Did the disciples in Acts four quote
scripture?
>> Yes. I want one word from you. They were
praying how
>> I said I want one word.
>> They were praying how?
>> It starts with a B,
>> then an I,
>> then a B,
then an L.
>> They were praying.
>> I want an adverb. They were praying
>> biblically.
I need a glass of water. [laughter]
Why is it so tough to get the right
answer out of you? But you're
vegetarians.
[laughter]
This is no joke. I'm exhausted.
Trying to get you to give me a simple
answer. If you pray from the Bible,
you're praying biblically.
>> That's the language of God. When in
France,
>> when with God? speak his language. It's
the word of God. In other words, pray
biblically.
>> Amen.
>> Because God cannot deny himself and he
is the word. By the way, Deuteronomy
32:4 tells us God is truth. John 14:6
tells us Jesus is truth. 1 John 5:6
tells us the Holy Ghost is truth. The
Father is truth. The Son is truth. The
Holy Ghost is truth. You want to be a
child of God, you've got to be a child
of truth.
>> And the truth is the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord thy God, not Sunday.
>> I hate to throw it in you so
unannounced.
Sunday is not the Sabbath.
>> It never has been.
>> It isn't now
>> and never will be. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Didn't I tell you this morning every
good gift? Well, not I, but I told you
the Bible said every good gift and every
perfect gift comes from where?
>> Where did the ten commandments come
from?
>> Didn't God come down?
>> On Sinai.
>> Unspoken.
>> He said the seventh day is the Sabbath.
>> That is part of a good gift
>> and a perfect gift.
>> Nobody's listening.
This good gift came from above
>> down to Sunday originated from beneath
>> and some people want to send it up.
>> Let me tell you a secret. Preaching is
hard work.
>> It's exhausting work.
>> What's our subject?
When with God, speak his language.
What's that?
>> You have financial hardship.
>> You go to God first. You apologize for
stealing.
>> What did I say? You apologize for
Not all thieves are in prison.
>> Not all thieves in Granite Bay are in
prison. Some come to church every
Sabbath.
You apologize for stealing. And then God
reminds you and you remind him, "Bring
ye all the tithe into the storehouse."
>> Amen.
>> That they may be meat in mine house. God
says, "Didn't I tell you that?" And you
have to say with humility, "Yes, you
said that." Then you say to God, "But
you said, I will pour you out a
blessing. There shall not be room enough
to receive it. Didn't you say that? And
God will say, "Yes." So, we have two-way
communication.
>> Pray in the language of God.
>> You've been studying the word, something
is a problem.
Father, you said in John 6:13, "How be
it, when he, the Spirit of truth, is
come, he will guide you into all truth."
Father, open mine eyes. Father, you said
in Psalm 119 verse 18, "Open thou mine
eyes that I may behold wondrous things
out of thy own." You did you say that?
Yes.
>> Psalm 32:8, I will instruct thee and
teach thee. Did you say that? Yes.
What's our subject?
>> When with God,
>> speak his language. And since we are
stressing prayer, when you pray, pray
biblically.
>> I'll tell you one other thing, then I'll
leave you alone. Time is flying. Father,
I'll come to an end. But don't end your
blessings upon me.
>> Amen.
>> By that I mean the spirit working
through me in Jesus name I pray. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Go to Isaiah 38:3 quickly.
Isaiah 38. You know, Hezekiah got the
bad news. Isaiah said, "Set thy house in
order. Thou shalt die and not live." He
has Hezekiah said, "Remember now, oh
Lord, I beseech thee, verse three, how I
have walked before thee in truth and
with a perfect heart, and I've done that
which is good in thy sight." Finish
verse three. And Hezekiah, come on,
wept.
What kind of praying is that? We go to
1st Samuel 1. 1st Samuel 1, we read
verse 10. Hannah was the second wife of
um Elca. Elca had two wives, Hannah and
Panina. One had a child, the other
couldn't. You know the embarrassment
that is particularly in that kind of
society. A man has many wives. Three of
them have children. You're the fourth.
You have none. Everyone thinks you're
cursed.
And so she's praying to God for a child.
Read verse 10 of 1st Samuel 1. What does
that say? And she was in bitterness of
spirit and prayed unto the Lord.
Finished the verse and wept. So remind
you of Hezekiah. She cried. Hezekiah
cried.
Go to Mark chapter 9 verse 23 and verse
24. Our subject when in France speak
French.
Mark chapter 9 second gospel. Shortest
gospel. He was not one of the 12
disciples nor was Luke by the way. But
they were apostles of Christ.
>> Just not among the 12. Do you have Mark
9?
Verse 23 says what [snorts]
>> condition. Jesus said
>> if thou can believe all things are
possible to him that believeth. Jesus
tells the father that because the father
wanted his epileptic boy cured. And
straightway the father cried out and
said what?
>> Now read the verse. And straightway the
father of the child, come on,
>> cried out and said
>> with tears,
>> Lord, I believe, help my unbeliever. He
cried.
Did Hezekiah cry?
>> Did Hannah cry?
>> Did this guy cry?
>> Go to Hebrews chapter 5. Let's read
verse seven.
>> Oh, thank you, sister. You're a nice
person. I like you.
Hebrews 5. Thank you. Thank you. I'm
going fast.
Slow down.
Don't break the speed limit.
You have Hebrews 5.
>> Now read verse 7. Please humor me. Read
for the first time nice and clear. If
you have my version, are you there?
>> Let's read. Who in the days of his flesh
when he had offered up praise and
supplication with strong crying and
tears unto him that was what? able to
save him from death and was hurt in that
he feared. Who is this Jesus? How did he
cry? With tears.
>> Now wait a minute. If Jesus could cry
when he prayed,
why should we pray casually? Listen to
me. We need more prayers with tears.
>> Amen.
>> You don't come to God. How you doing?
I'll be right back as soon as the
playoff is finished. Uh-uh. Mm- mm- You
come to God and God says, "Show me
something." Because I'm from Missouri.
Are you with me? Show me something.
>> Show me something. When God told
Abraham, "Sacrifice Isaac." The Bible
says Abraham rose up early in the
morning, saddled his ass, took two of
his young men with him, took Isaac his
son, cut the wood, gave the wood to
Isaac, started traveling, and built the
altar, put the word in order, bound
Isaac his son, raised the knife. God
said, "Now I know.
You've shown me something. Now I know.
Thou fairest me." Abraham showed him
something. God said to Hezekiah, I have
heard thy prayers. I have seen thy
tears. He surely said to Hannah, "I've
seen your tears." He said to that man
through Jesus Christ, "He, I see your
tears." And of course to his son, "I see
your tears." But he could not deliver
the son.
He had to die for you and me.
>> We need to do a little more crying
>> when we pray.
>> Amen.
>> Let's say you sit an exam for medical
school and you flunked.
You sat to cry
because it's important to you and all
your friends will know and your family.
You get a notice from the IRS. You're
being what's the word? Um
>> audited.
>> Audited. And the evidence says that you
owe us $2 million and we want it next
week.
And you start to cry.
Or you get some news. You're pregnant
and examination 8 months and the child
has already had a cancer in the liver at
8 months in your womb and you start to
cry.
We should cry over this thing. But the
thing about which we should cry more
than any other is sin.
You can go to heaven with one leg and
we'll give you another. Not we. God will
give you another leg. You can go to
heaven with a hearing impairment. God
will fix it.
You cannot go
>> with sin.
>> This means I'm done.
>> What's our subject?
>> When in France,
>> what's the language of God?
>> His word.
>> When you're in his presence, in his
country, in his territory, speak his
language.
>> Amen.
>> He understands and he cannot what? deny
it.
>> You must make a commitment to God right
now. You must.
>> That's the way intelligent person
listens to the word. Make a commit. How
many of you will say, "Father, help me
when I pray to pray in your language."
Can I see your hand
>> now? Do you mean that?
>> Stand up with me.
>> Don't just raise it to please me. Raise
it because you mean it.
But in order to do that, you have to
know the word to know what to say.
>> Don't accuse God falsely. You don't say,
"Father, did you not say Sunday is the
Sabbath?" "I never said that," says God.
So you've got to know it, which means
you have to study it. Elaw White tells
us Christ's object lessons, page 100,
paragraph 1. If studied and obeyed, the
word of God works in the heart, subduing
every unholy attribute.
The ministry of healing page 458
paragraph 2. The reason why so many
youth and even those of mature years are
so easily led into temptation and sin is
because they do not study the word of
God and meditate upon it as they should.
Our minds are occupied with everything.
Some legitimate, some illegitimate.
This should occupy our minds more than
anything else.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> This made the universe.
>> Amen.
>> This is the name of God.
>> This raised Lazarus.
>> Amen.
>> This rebuked diseases.
>> The word cast out demons.
>> It is by the word Jesus forgave. He
said, "Thy sins be forgiven." It is all
by the word. The language of God. When
in France,
>> speak.
>> When with God, speak his language, the
word of God.
>> Heads bowed. Eyes closed.
Dear God,
if I said anything I should not have
said, I apologize to you.
If I was too hard on your people,
forgive me, dear God.
I hope, Father, something was said
through me by your spirit that blessed
somebody.
I hope someone will leave this place,
Father, determined to master learn the
language of God.
the word so that he or she might speak
to you in your language the word because
you cannot deny the word.
Bless everyone who heard in this
building and online dear God
as they study the word and meditate upon
the word. Father, let that divine
radiation kill the cells the cancerous
cells in their lives of sin. Amen.
>> Dear God, thank you for the pleasure,
the honor, the privilege of speaking for
you. Help me, Father, to do better next
time. Put a double blessing on the
children, dear God. And if someone needs
to forgive someone, let them make a
choice right now to forgive
or to say, "I'm sorry for having done
this or that." Bless this church, all
churches represented. Bless those
online. Let us make an effort father by
the help of your spirit to make prayer
our number one exercise and work in the
name of Jesus Christ I pray. Let God's
people say amen and amen. God bless you.
Please be seated.
We have been blessed. It's not finished
yet. There's more. We're going to take
some of your Bible questions now. We're
going to take just a short time to set
up the stage. If you would like to scan
a Bible question, you can. You'll see
the QR code. They're going to put it up
on the screen. Just point your camera to
that and you can take a picture of that.
And then we'll have our Bible Q&A with
our speakers in about 5 minutes.
>> [music]
>> Heat.
Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Well, welcome back everyone. We'd like
to welcome all of you to our Bible Q&A.
Our topic is on prayer and we're going
to be wrapping up this afternoon
presentation. Couple of reminders. Uh
our program continues tomorrow morning.
We have a special prayer workshop and
that is going to start at 8:30
breakfast. The actual prayer workshop
will start at 900 a.m. tomorrow morning.
Uh they've asked just to kind of get an
idea of the preparations for breakfast.
If uh those of you who are planning to
be up for breakfast, if you could just
raise your hand this those are going to
be for our prayer summit. I want to kind
of just get an idea a feel of what we're
looking at.
All right, that's good. Okay, so be at
8:30. Breakfast is going to be served in
the fellowship hall and uh then we'll go
into uh the actual workshop itself. Uh
depending on the group, it might be in
here or it might be in the chapel and
we'll be able to continue all the way
till noon. So take advantage of that. Uh
also just want to remind our friends who
are joining us online, if you don't know
yet, we do have a free offer that we
want to tell you about. A book written
by Pastor Doug. It's called Teach Us to
Pray. And this is our free gift to any
of those who are watching. All you have
to do is text the word pray 26 to the
number 40544
and you'll be able to get a digital
download or you can just scan the QR
code that you see there on your screen
and uh that'll be a great blessing to
you and you can share the book with
somebody else. Also uh we have uh Pastor
Jerry Pages book. They are available at
the back in the church lobby. So, make
sure that you pick this up as you leave
today as well as the book Teach Us to
Pray for those of you who are here in
person.
Okay. Well, we're going to get right to
our Bible questions. We're trying to
cover as many as we can. So, thank you.
We're going to have a word of prayer and
then get started at kind of the way it
works. Thank you for all of the
questions. We have 127 questions so far
and they're growing all the time. But
I'm trying to focus at least at first
questions related to prayer because that
is our main theme that we are looking at
today. But before we get into it, Pastor
Doug, would you open with a word of
prayer?
Father in heaven, uh this theme for the
weekend is teach us to pray. And I pray
that you'll even quicken the minds of
those who will do our best to answer the
questions. Uh bring to our remembrance
the things we've studied and speak.
Lord, we pray that we can learn how to
pray better and better understand your
will and your your character. We ask
that you bless this segment in Jesus
name. Amen.
>> Amen. All right, I'm going to get going
here. As you can see, I'm using my phone
because I'm looking at the questions
coming in live. All right, first
question that we have. How can I tell if
God is speaking to me rather than just
my own thoughts? All of you can kind of
share. How do I know if it's God
speaking to me or just my own thoughts?
>> I'll jump in just with there's probably
several ways you can do this, but one is
um if God is speaking to you, it's going
to be in harmony with his word for one
thing. So, if something is coming to you
and you're wondering, is this my
conscience? But it's contrary to the
word, that would not be God speaking to
you.
>> All right, you got the word of God as a
test. What else? What about things that
seem to be in harmony with God's word?
How do you know?
>> Say that again.
>> Uh things that are both seemingly in
harmony with God's will. In other words,
both would be okay. How do you know what
God is telling you?
>> Which one will give God more glory?
>> Mhm.
>> Choose that one.
>> Amen.
>> Right. Amen. Good. All right. Here's the
next one. Do you have to say in Jesus'
name every time you pray?
>> Yes.
>> In order for your prayer to be heard?
>> Yes. Yes. I Let me do this one. Yes.
Yes.
If you do not pray in the name of Jesus,
you do not understand the atonement,
there is nothing God the Father can do
for you unless he does it through
Christ.
>> Are you with me?
>> To pray in the name of Jesus is to
acknowledge that he's God. He's the
creator. He was fully man. He resisted
all temptation. He voluntarily laid down
his life. He raised himself. He's now
our intercessor. All of that must be
part of your consciousness. as you pray
in the name of Jesus. Jesus says no man
cometh unto the father but by me. I've
heard so many people pray to God and say
in your name in the name of Jesus. This
must be deliberate and intentional.
You're letting God know you are aware
that is because of Christ that he can
bless you. Elise said the cross of
Calvary is stamped upon every loaf of
bread. Never pray unless you pray in the
name of Jesus.
>> Now if you do it ignorantly that's one
thing but to be a child of God for many
years and not understand it all comes
through Jesus is to reveal that you do
not understand the role of Jesus Christ.
Pray in his name. He tells us if he
shall ask anything in my name I will do
it. Pray in the name of Jesus.
>> Amen. Amen. All right. Following up on
that same question, when a person prays,
do they pray to the father as Jesus has
taught? Is it okay though to pray to the
son and can we pray to the holy spirit?
>> Well, let me answer that too. [laughter]
Sorry, sorry, sorry. Look at the prayer
of Jesus in John 17. Six times he said,
"Father, father." He never said, "Holy
Spirit,
>> he prayed to the father every time at
the tomb of Lazarus. Father, I thank you
thou has heard me. John 12, Father,
glorify thy name. Father, Father,
Father. He never prayed to the Holy
Ghost. The Holy Ghost is fully God. But
we're told by Jesus, pray to the Father
>> in the name of the Son.
>> We thank God for the Holy Ghost who
intercedes for us. But we pray to God in
the name of Jesus. By the way, Acts 20
21, you repent to God and you have faith
in Jesus. Let me say it again. You
repent to God
and faith in Jesus. Elroy writes the
same thing. Uh, great controversy, page
467, paragraph 3 or 4. Repent to God
because his law has been transgressed,
but have faith in the atoning sacrifice.
Repent to the father in the name of
Jesus Christ on the basis of his
sacrifice. We have no example of Christ
praying to the Holy Ghost.
>> All right. Very good. Yes, Pastor Doug.
Having said that,
virtually every time in the Bible, we're
encouraged to pray to the father with a
couple of exceptions. Steven dying said,
"Lord Jesus, receive my spirit."
>> The last words in the Bible, even so
come, Lord Jesus. But that does not
contradict what Elder Ske said.
>> All right. Very good. So when a little
child prays and says, "Dear Jesus,"
that's that's appropriate, right? U uh
but again the example given in scripture
would be
>> why are children taught to pray to God
the Father?
>> Good question. Why do children typically
told Jesus is nicer than the father?
>> It's the father who sent Jesus. If you
ask 10 little children to pray, they all
pray to Jesus. We are not giving people
the right view of the father.
>> The father himself love you.
>> Yes, that would uh let me shut up. All
right. Here we go. Good. Good.
Now, this is a good question. I think
it's one that we all face from time to
time. When prayers go seemingly
unanswered or unanswered, is that a no,
a not yet, or something entirely else?
Yes.
No. I think God has so many ways of
doing what's right for us. And if we
worry about the timing or we worry about
exactly what he's giving us, we're
missing how big he is and what he sees
as best in our life. So, you know, I I
don't think it's a no.
All right. So, it could be no, it could
be not yet. Uh, let me follow that up
with another question just to make it a
little more challenging. Let's say
somebody's praying for something and
they're not getting an answer. Do they
assume they need to just keep praying?
What if it's not God's will? Is there a
point where you just say, "All right,
Lord, I'm leaving this with you. I'm
moving on with something else. I'm not
going to keep bringing it up." Or do we
keep praying and praying until we get
what we think we want? Abraham prayed
for 25 years before Isaac was born. He
came into Canaan at 75. He had Isaac
when he was 100. Isaac married Rebecca
when he was 40. He had Jacob and Esau
when he was 60. He prayed 20 years. I'm
not saying everyone has to pray that
long. But the fact that God does not
answer according to our schedule does
not mean he will not answer. God does
things in his time. And so keep Elise
said the things God will not do for us
if we don't pray. He also said many
things he doesn't do because we stop
praying too soon. Pray with
determination.
>> Amen.
>> All right. How do we pray in God's will?
>> How do we
>> how do we pray in God's will? In other
words, if if if things aren't working
out the way we think it should work out,
how do we get ourselves back in line
with his will?
There's a few times you got evangelists
just sitting there looking at you.
Usually they always got an answer. How
do you pray in God's will?
>> Well, first of all, you want to be
praying in accordance with the
scriptures. [snorts]
>> It says uh his will is his word. The
commandments of God are the will of God.
Um, sometimes when you have two those
things are in harmony, you might also
seek Christian counsel in the multitude
of counsel and that would be good
counsel. There's safety. I do believe
God speaks to us sometimes through the
Holy Spirit. But you got to be careful
because sometimes people confuse
hunger with the Holy Spirit. And there's
a lot of things that could sometimes uh
confuse us as a counterfeit for the Holy
Spirit. Um, so sometimes it's a
combination of providential openings,
the word, Christian counsel, and just
the the moving of the spirit that gives
us peace. I do believe sometimes we if
we really asking Jesus to show us his
will and we're in the Bible while we're
praying, sometimes a verse that isn't
necessarily on that specific topic will
speak to us. And I at least I know that
when father's doing that for me, he's
just saying this this answer is for you.
Okay. Amen.
>> In John 15:7, Jesus said, "If you abide
in me, and my words abide in you, you
shall ask what you will, it shall be
done unto you." The word abide, the
Greek word men means to stay, to
continue to remain. If you live
according to God's word, it is the
living principle in your life. You come
to the place where what you ask is what
God would ask for you.
>> The word in you instructs you what to
ask.
One more thing on that. I just remember
George Mueller used to say, "The biggest
problem in understanding God's will is
first being willing to do whatever that
is."
>> And Jesus said, "If any man is willing
to do his will, he will know the
doctrine whether it be of God."
>> Well, you know, pastor, you bring up a
good point. If you want to be honest
with ourselves,
usually there might be some exceptions,
but almost always if you are sincerely
praying, saying, "Lord, what is it you
wish for me to do?" The Holy Spirit
usually gives you a pretty good idea
based on the word of God, based on what
you know is right, what steps you need
to take. Often our prayer needs to be,
Lord, give me the strength to do what I
know you want me to do. I think often
that's the bigger challenge that we face
than necessarily knowing God's will.
It's having the courage to do what we
know God wants us to do. All right. You
mentioned hunger for just a few moments
ago. This is a great question. Um could
you explain a little bit about the need
for prayer and fasting? Uh why don't we
start with that one? What is the purpose
of prayer and fasting? And maybe the
second part is what does it actually do?
Why does fasting seem to increase your
prayer power than if you just prayed and
does it? How does pray and fasting work?
>> I've got a lot of answers, but I'm going
to wait. I want to give the the other
gentlemen a chance to to say something,
but if they don't say anything, I will.
>> Well, I think part of it's physical. I
think if we keep our our mind cleaner,
clearer, you know, we can hear his voice
and and understand his will better. But,
you know, I think there's a part of
sacrifice in it, too. And saying, I'm
willing to I'm serious enough about this
God to actually deny myself some
something for a while. And it may be
fasting. Fasting isn't always about
food. Fasting is often I'm going to shut
off my phone. Would that be a good idea,
wouldn't it? Yeah. Or [laughter]
media, you know, all kinds of fasts I
think are really important, but we it
does clear our mind to hear him better.
Self-denial is the fundamental
principle. Selfdenial,
which is what Christ practiced in John
8:29.
And he that have sent me is with me. The
father hath not left me alone, for I do
always those things that please him.
What this means is this. Jesus all his
earthly life, he fasted from self.
That's more challenging than fasting
from food. He fasted his entire life was
a fast. He fasted from self. He said, "I
do always." It's not that there weren't
things he wanted to do. He only did what
the father wanted. He fasted from self.
That's what Eli said in the garden of
Gethsemane when he almost went back. He
said he died the second death. She said
in that garden because he died
absolutely to self. So when [snorts] you
fast, you're denying yourself something.
And self-denial is the very heart of
God.
>> All right. Maybe another thought related
to fasting. It does seem when you look
in the Bible when you have the people of
Israel fasting or the disciples fasting
in a group, it seems as though they
facing some very serious situation. You
think of Esther for example, uh you
think of Daniel who spent time fasting.
It was it was a turning point. It was a
key point in the destiny of Israel. It
was a call for repentance and revival.
And when Jesus was asked, why is it that
uh you know John's disciples fast but
yours don't fast? And Jesus said, 'Well,
can they fast while they got the
bridegroom?
>> Well, the time was coming, Jesus said,
when they would fast.
>> And I I think in one way, yes, fasting
is important, but it doesn't really have
power until we realize an issue at
stake. I remember in my own life where
at one point a very dear friend was
diagnosed with you know a death sentence
just a terrible um diagnosis uh and I I
fasted and prayed like I never fast and
prayed before there was there was a
deepness there was an urgency I said
Lord we don't want to lose him you have
to do something and it wasn't so much a
generated fast like I need to stop
eating but it was just an overwhelming
need that I had for Jesus
>> and I think that's going to become God's
people their experience more and more as
we reach the end. Right? We're going to
sense our need of Jesus more than our
daily food. All right. Well, I'm not
supposed to answer the questions. I'm
just supposed to ask the questions.
>> Go ahead.
>> All right. Here's the next one.
Is it okay to ask God to forgive the
sins of our kids and neighbors even
though they didn't seem to ask for
forgiveness?
>> Yes.
Uh well, the Bible says while we were
yet sinners, Christ Jesus died for us.
>> If we were supposed to, God was supposed
to wait until we all asked for
forgiveness before he died for us, we'd
be in big trouble. And another reason
you want to forgive people, and it
doesn't mean you need to let them
continue taking advantage of you. But if
if you don't forgive people,
that unforgiveness is a poison that
destroys its container. It hurts you. So
sometimes you've got to let it go and
forgive them and u for your own benefit.
>> Were you you're talking about us asking
God to forgive them or us forgiving
them?
>> Well, I think first of all, yes, we need
to forgive them. But can we pray for
others when we know they are sinning?
They're not asking for forgiveness on
their own. Can can we intercede on their
behalf asking God to forgive them?
I'm not sure I know the answer, but I
know that uh you know Isaiah where it
talks about Isaiah 44 uh praying for the
Holy Spirit upon our children. I think
we can do that whether they want him or
not. That's a little different than the
question you're asking, but I think
that's important to do. They may not
want the Holy Spirit. They may not be
asking for it. So forgiveness, I'm not
sure.
>> Job offered sacrifices for his children.
>> I was thinking about that one
>> in case they had sinned. He didn't know.
that he now those sacrifices had effect.
Now I cannot say I can say God forgive
him but certainly my prayer can put a
hedge of protection around him until he
comes to the point where he realizes he
needs to confess because prayer have
power. Prayers have power. So yes you
can pray for someone. Daniel prayed in
Daniel 9, forgive us. But he had done
nothing.
>> But he prayed. He confessed the sins of
his ancestors and asked God to forgive.
>> And Jesus prayed on the cross. Father,
forgive them
>> for they know not what they're doing.
Now, that doesn't mean that they all
were saved. But if they turned, they
would be forgiven. Christ the deceit on
their behalf.
>> And the same thing was Steven when he
was dying. He said, "Lord, lay not this
sin to their charge, but he was praying
for them to be forgiven for what they
were doing to him. It wasn't praying for
general forgiveness for everything they
had done."
>> I think we can choose to say, "Lord,
don't hold what they've done to me
against their account."
>> All right. Next question that we have.
I'm wondering if there are different
types of prayers and would you be able
to just describe what type of prayer and
when we would use a particular prayer?
>> Would you read the question again
please?
>> I'm wondering if there are different
types of prayers and would you describe
when to use a particular prayer?
>> Nehemiah did a this dart prayer thing
because he didn't have time to think it
all through or get the scriptures or
whatever. So that's one. Okay. Any
others types of prayers and when we use
it?
>> Parents, I'm sure, offer intercessory
prayers on behalf of their children. You
can offer standing in the gap, standing
for somebody. You can offer a prayer of
praise without asking God for anything,
just thanking God, thanking God,
thanking God. So there are prayers of
gratitude. They're prayers, prayers of
praise, and their prayers of
intercession.
And then there's prayers I think of
leading. You know, in the Lord's prayer,
it says, "Lead us not into temptation."
That's really saying, "Lead us away from
our natural bent to temptation." So,
we're asking for guidance often.
All right. Maybe about same topic, but
when would we pray a particular type of
prayer? I mean, we can pray anytime, but
is there different times when we need to
pray different prayers? I'm thinking,
for example, in corporate worship,
there's a type of prayer that we pray
when we come together here. There is a
type of prayer that we pray in the
family circle with the children and then
there's personal prayer. Can you say
something about the different those
different types of prayer?
I think praise uh in times of trial,
praise when when we're having a lot of
problems, that kind of thing is really
powerful. Uh if we don't just sit around
and mope or just plead for God to take
everything away, but we we just really
focus praise on him, it can change the
whole attitude of depression. that kind
of thing. So, I've seen that a lot.
>> So, praise, that's an important part of
prayer. Have you been to prayer meetings
where you kind of hear the same thing
over and over again in prayer meeting
where they praying for somebody's uh
knee that's giving them problems? You
know, we pray for health, don't we? But
it does seem as though sometimes we just
fall into a rut where we praying the
same thing over and over again. And I
think we need to be aware of that. And
you want to balance out the prayer. Some
guidance that we have in corporate
prayer. Uh the prayers need to be short.
Is that correct? To the point. You don't
want long public prayers. I think in the
family circle, I'm answering my question
here. When you pray with a family, I
think you want to keep it short and to
the point, especially if there's
children involved. And of course, when
you're on your knees before the Lord or
you're praying before the Lord privately
or maybe two or three, that's when you
take the time, right? You pour your
heart out to the Lord in prayer. How
many times did Daniel pray? Morning,
noon, and night. I think he prayed a
little longer. probably in the evening
or the morning than he did at noon
because he was on his lunch break, you
would think, right? So, there are
different times for different lengths or
types of prayer.
>> There's also conversational prayer where
you just talk to God.
>> Amen.
>> You're stuck in traffic, discuss it with
God. You're in the supermarket, the
prices have gone up, you just discuss it
with God. You just talk to God
conversationally
just to be talking to God. That's all.
While you're doing that, Satan has to
wait because you're busy talking.
>> But the moment you stop, you see talk to
God. The Bible says, "Pray without
ceasing." It's a discipline we have to
practice. Keep your mind always in
contact with heaven. For instance, I can
sit there and say, "Father, half the
people are not here this afternoon.
Where did they go to give Bible studies?
Where are they?" So, you just talk to
God. Are you following me?
Conversational prayer. just chat with
God.
>> And that's that's where I would wonder
when you say you always must uh say it's
to the father in Jesus' name. U
conversational prayer really having a
practice of presence throughout the
whole day. I'm not sure the addressing
is the important part. That's my
opinion.
You know, years ago, I used to always
talk to God when I was driving and I was
so thankful when they invented cell
phones. So people are always talking on
their phone and you see their mouth
moving when they're in the car next to
you. And now I can talk to God and
people just think I'm on the phone. And
so it's a lot more comfortable now than
it used to be.
>> But uh I do I just drive down the road,
I talk to the Lord out loud and um it's
uh and you listen, you speak, your mind
wanders, and you come back and you talk
to him some more. That's just wonderful
communi communication that way.
>> All right, we got a lot of practical
things during this weekend. Here's a
good practical question. How can you
help me with my prayers that my mind
doesn't wonder? Is is there something I
can think of when I pray? We know how
that is. We've had a long day. We start
praying and we start thinking about
things we didn't get done or things we
still need to do. We got to bring our
mind back. What are some practical
things we could do to to make prayer
life more meaningful that way?
>> Journaling is one thing that can help. I
don't write a lot, but sometimes when my
mind's wandering, I like to write down
the requests in place to for them to be
answered or to even write a short
letter, that kind of thing.
>> All right. So, writing down things while
you pray. What else?
>> You can actually pray through a
scripture. You know, if you go to the
Psalms and you read the Psalms, many of
the Psalms are prayers that you can buy
into. There are psalms that are psalms
of praise. that are psalms that are
psalms of anger, frustration,
depression, and as you read them, you
can say, "Lord, I resonate with this."
And it it keeps you focused as you go
through the verses in that psalm. Pause
between verses and reflect on your own
heart's need in relation to that
passage.
>> All right, another question. God loves
us individually. He's a God of love. But
why does it seem that there is more
power when praying with someone or in a
group than when you're praying on your
own? And is there more power when you're
praying in a group?
>> Ellen White's letter to the Farnsworth
that I used last night is she says
there's more power because of the unity
of heart as we do it. Now I know when we
pray together we don't always agree but
when we do agree I think it's like the
upper room people the Holy Spirit is
able to do something more with us and we
have oneness of spirit that's very
important.
>> Okay. It's a unity of purpose when we
praying together.
>> Well, Christ says in the mouth of two or
three witnesses, let something be
established. And I think again the the
united testimony, the united appeal, um
we we show our our love to the world by
our love for one another. And um I just
know that when I am singing with others,
it sounds so much better. So,
all right. Next question is kind of a
little bit of a a very important
question. I'm going to come back to the
other one I saw. How do I plead for the
Holy Spirit?
>> How do I what?
>> Plead for the Holy Spirit? How do I pray
or plead for the Holy Spirit?
>> Is it just a matter of saying, "Please,
Lord, give me the Holy Spirit." Is that
what's involved in asking for the Holy
Spirit?
>> There are three things I recommend. One,
Luke 11:13. If ye then, being evil, know
how to give good gifts unto your
children, how much more shall a heavenly
father give the Holy Spirit to them that
ask. So you ask if you want the Holy
Spirit. Acts 5:32. And we are his
witnesses of these things, and so is
also the Holy Ghost, whom God has given
to them that obey him. So you should
ask, are you obeying [snorts] God in
your life? Acts 2 37:38. Now when they
heard this, they were pricricked in
their hearts and said unto Peter and to
the rest of the apostles, men and
brethren, what shall we do? Then Peter
said,"Repent and be baptized, every one
of you, in the name of Jesus Christ for
the remission of sins, and ye shall
receive the gift of the Holy Ghost." So
we have three conditions. Ask, yes, but
that's not enough. Obey God in your
daily life, and if you have not yet done
it, be baptized.
>> There may be others, but I think of
these three.
>> All right. Very good.
>> And pray with persistence. Mhm.
>> Don't give up.
>> Amen.
>> Here's a practical question that
somebody is asking um to all of the
speakers. What is your morning prayer
routine look like?
>> What does your morning prayer routine
look like? What do you do?
>> Pass it out. Why don't we start?
>> Well, I shared a little bit when I spoke
if you were here this morning that u my
custom is I wake up. You know, it takes
a few minutes to get your scoops
together when you first get out of bed.
I don't know about you, but I I don't
think very clear. So, I wake up and I I
heat up some water and I go to the
office and uh I splash some water on my
face and I get on my knees and I pray
and um sometimes I have to stay there
for a while because it takes a while for
the fog to lift and I start thinking
about the needs. There's always a lot
going on. Needs in the church. There are
families in our church that have special
needs. needs in our family, needs for
the ministry, and just the work of God
around the world. There's just so many
needs. Um, and of course, I can always I
always always pray for the Holy Spirit
every day. It's like breath. You've got
to every day pray for the spirit. And
among the things we've discussed, when
you pray for the spirit, believe. Ask ye
of the Lord, rain in the time of the
latter rain, and he'll send flashing
clouds. We need to believe. He'll give
you the spirit. He wants to. and I
believe he will.
>> All right, Pastor Paige, what is your
morning prayer routine?
>> Uh, I really, it depends. I try to be
genuine, but I like to praise first. I
really, and I like to pray with my Bible
open and I love the Psalms and other
places where I can find in any scripture
a way to thank him for his character
because I think if I do that, it puts me
in a mindset for confession and for
intercession and other things. But you
know, I I there's certain promises that
I just love to claim in the morning and
even about my sin. I've shared one of
them here about u the need to have him
totally control my life and I give
permission. You mentioned consecration
every morning and those kind of things.
But I I really like praying with my
Bible open and that's how I God often
speaks to me through that and I try to
write it down sometimes when he says
something so specific or he gives me
instruction for the day. when I was a
conference president, I used to need a
lot of counsel. I still do, but uh it
was just beautiful when he would tell me
exactly what what to do, you know, or
give me something like that.
>> Amen.
Uh very similar to these two servants of
God. Uh the moment I open my eyes, I
start to talk. I thank God for life.
Before just as soon as my eyes open and
I realize I am not dead, I start
praying. I say thank you for life. Thank
you Lord.
>> Amen.
>> Recommmit my life to you. I know you
don't need me, but I recommmit the life.
And in the prayer, I recite Bible
verses. In the prayer, I said, "Father,"
in other words, I try to pray
biblically. I think that's what you
said. If I say, "Father, forgive me,"
then I may quote Psalm 32 or Psalm 51.
And uh but there's a lot of reciting of
scripture in the praying that I do. But
as soon as I open my eye, our high
calling page 116 paragraph 2, Ellen
White writes, "Your last thought at
night, your first thought in the morning
should be of him in whom is centered
your hope of eternal life." And so I try
to practice as soon as my eyes are open,
I thank God for life and I start talking
to him.
Just to add to that a little bit, you
know what helped me many years ago um to
kind of direct my prayer. I thought of
the word pray. P R A Y and you got P and
I think that stands for praise. That
would be the acronym. R is repentance. A
is ask. And the Y is healed. And I
actually go through those four points
when I pray.
>> And I begin with praise. And what I try
to do when I think of something to
praise God for, I have to stop and you
got to think for a little bit. You got
to think and say, "Lord, what can I
praise you for?
>> What am I thankful for?" And you want to
be specific that day.
>> Say, "Lord, I want to praise you for
this." And you know, as you stop and
listen, things will come to mind and you
say, "Oh, that's right, Lord. I didn't
think of that.
>> You helped me there. You helped me
there." And then, of course, you go on
to R and you do the same thing. You got
to be specific. Lord, what did I do
wrong that offended you today? Could be
an attitude, could be a word, whatever
it is. And the Holy Spirit will bring it
to your remembrance and you go, "That's
right, Lord." And of course, you ask and
you heal. You surrender yourself to God.
I find that when you do that, you have
structure to your prayer. Praying for
10, 15 minutes,
20 minutes, 30 minutes, it just
disappears. I mean, it just flies by.
and you allow the Holy Spirit to kind of
speak to you and you don't rush through
your prayers.
>> Speak and wait. Let the Holy Spirit
guide you. Look up verses. Connect it
with scripture. It makes prayer
meaningful that way. All right. [snorts]
>> A couple other questions that we have.
Um, we have a great one here, but I'm
looking live and so I find a great
question and then somebody posts a
question and then the question I want to
ask disappears, but I think I remember
what it was. Oh, here it is. I found it.
Will the latter rain, it's a good
question. Will the latter rain be
evident to everyone or will only the
wheat and the tears have the spiritual
discernment to see it? Talking about the
latter rain.
>> Who wants to talk about the latter rain?
The Holy Spirit. Yes.
>> Could you say that again?
>> I didn't get the question.
>> Read it again.
>> Oh, sorry. Read it again. It's a little
hard to hear up here with the echo.
>> Echo. Yeah. Will the latter rain be
evident to everyone?
Or will only the wheat and the tears
have the spiritual discernment to see
it?
>> The wheat and the tears.
>> The wheat and the tears in the church.
Yeah.
>> Tears have the spiritual discernment to
see anything. No. No.
>> Tears aren't going to make it. No.
>> Some won't realize it's happening. We
know that for sure. But tears, you threw
me with that. I don't the tears.
>> I think the question means will people
in the church who would be in the tear
category recognize that something's
happening.
>> I think they're going to
>> they won't know what it is something to
be happening but they don't know it's
the Holy Spirit.
>> You know I would answer that question
with a question. The former reign can
teach you something about the latter
reign. Did the apostles know at
Pentecost that God had poured the spirit
upon them? Jesus said, "Wait in
Jerusalem. be praying and you shall
receive power from on high. And they
knew said, "What you see today is the
fulfillment of Joel chapter 2 is what
Peter said in the sermon." I think that
if we're preparing our hearts, they
prepared their hearts. They were praying
10 days together. They were putting
aside their differences. They were
repenting of their sins. They were
humbling themselves. As they prepared
their hearts, when the Holy Spirit was
poured out, they knew the place was
shaken
>> and they had tongues of fire and they
were able to speak a way they had never
spoken before. I think it would have
been hard for them to miss that. And I
think when God pours out the latter
rain, it's not going to be lesser in
quantity or quality than the former
rain. So, I think the the wheat, the
true believers will know. And I think
the world around us is going to be in a
really dramatic situation, too. That's
my personal opinion. And I wish it could
come easy, but I think it's going to
come under a dramatic uh problem that
we're going to be pleading and fasting
and you know, it's it's going to be
obvious that the miracles are beginning
to happen. She said that, you know, when
after this thing where the Protestants
reach out to the to the Catholics and
everything, she said that, you know, the
next thing to happen would be Satan's
false miracles and then God's miracles
come after that. So I think we will
begin to see a lot more miracles too u
as we're moving into that.
>> Yeah, absolutely. You know, you notice
when you look at scripture, there's a
special outpouring of the Holy Spirit in
fulfillment to some prophetic uh
prophecy that's given. Jesus spoke about
the Holy Spirit coming on his disciples.
It was fulfillment to his prophecy. John
the Baptist calling people to
repentance. There was a great revival.
Uh we know that there is a great revival
coming at the fulfillment of prophecy
too. And like you say, I think when
these things begin to take place, it's
going to awaken the church. Like the
loud cry that woke up the 10 virgins and
they all went back and trimmed their
lamps
>> and the wise had the extra oil in their
vessels. So there is going to be some
prophetic event, I think, that's going
to draw God's people together and
they're going to recognize if we don't
have the Holy Spirit, there's no way
we're going to make it through.
>> Amen. You know, while you're speaking, I
also remembered, did Elisha know when
the spirit of Elijah came upon him? He
did. He asked for it and he said, "Where
is the Lord God of Elijah?" And he
struck the water and it parted and the
sons of the prophets said, "The spirit
of Elijah rests upon Elisha." When God
told Moses, "Your leaders and judges
need your spirit." They gathered there
at the tabernacle and God took the
spirit that was from Moses and put it on
the judges. They prophesied. They knew.
Even Elad and Midad who didn't come,
they were baptized in the Holy Spirit.
They knew. And so, I think that we're
going to know. There'll be a counterfeit
first. But I think God's people are
going to know when we have that spirit.
All right. If God is sovereign, here's
the next question. And I'm trusting in
him. Can I just let him fulfill his will
and not worry about laboring in the Lord
in prayer, asking for something? Can't I
just say, "Well, Lord, I trust you.
Whatever your will is for me, you take
care of it."
>> Man, we just went through John 13:17.
Jesus in his last words to the disciples
says, "Ask, ask, ask, ask, ask, ask
seven times." So, I I think it's a rule
in the great controversy that he can't
give us things because we don't ask. So,
it's easy to say, "I'll just let the
Lord fix it all. I won't worry about
it." But I he says he wants us involved
with him and involved with the
intercession. And boy, when when I see
inter prayers intercessory prayers
answered, it it draws me to Jesus. It it
pumps me up. And so I think he wants us
to have the joy of seeing what we've
asked for answered.
>> Okay. Next question. Tying into what you
mentioned there, the importance of
intercessory prayer. Uh how does that
work? Why does it seem that when one
intercedes for somebody else, God is
able to do more to reach that person? I
mean, surely God doesn't love that
person anymore or less because of our
prayers. How does intercessory prayer
work?
>> Well, I was really impressed when Elder
Ski quoted all of John 17 last night. I
just know the first few verses.
>> But in that prayer, Jesus is interceding
for the apostles. So he's given us an
example that we should also intercede
and he's praying for church members
um who are struggling. And um I think
that as we as we enter into prayer in
behalf of others, for one thing, it
empties us of self. And even in the
Lord's prayer, I'm praying, Lord, lead
us, feed us, guide us, so forth, deliver
us. I'm not just concerned about my
leading, feeding, guiding. I want to be
concerned about yours. You can also see
in the Bible that when the prophets were
repenting of sin, David is confessing
his sin and the sin of his people.
That's an intercessory prayer. He he
tied himself in with it. Nehemiah said,
"Lord, forgive me and our people." So, I
think that we ought to bear one
another's burdens, and the Lord loves
that.
>> I I my wife is really an intercessor for
others, and she had some trouble with
depression early on and things, but when
she prays for others, she always quotes
Job, you know, when he prayed for his
friends, he was delivered kind of thing.
And so, I I think there's there's just
great power in being unselfish in our
prayers. I wish I was more unselfish
lots of times. She's always got others
on her mind and it's wonderful.
>> Mention something maybe about the great
controversy between good and evil. Are
they I think you might have mentioned it
u elder Alder Paige about sort of rules
of engagement in the great controversy
and how intercessory prayer might come
into that. You want to just recap that?
I found that very interesting.
>> Actually Angel Rodriguez who was BRRI
director we were riding along in in
Nigeria and we started talking about
prayer. He said we need to do a theology
of prayer. But he said he believed with
all his heart that prayer was a rule of
engagement in the war and that happens.
You know there's war crimes if you
aren't chosen. God somehow has great
great controversy says this. You know
Lord has limited himself in some ways to
our prayers. And so why does it help
somebody? My parents prayed for me so
much and other kids didn't. Um I don't
know but I think it works.
>> All right. Amen.
All right. Another practical question.
How do I get over my fear of praying
publicly?
I heard somebody agree with that. Maybe
there's some out here a little nervous
about praying in public. How do we get
over that fear?
Why do we have it? I mean, I think, you
know, just talked about self a lot, but
I think, you know, why why are we afraid
to speak in public or talk? We're afraid
we're not going to do good. We're people
going to feel bad about us. Isn't that
really worrying about us? And if we can
somehow focus on Jesus more and see how
unselfish he is and I'm not saying
anybody that's afraid to pray out loud
is selfish. But I think there's a aspect
of that maybe. But just doing it and and
seeing the the power it can have in
other people's lives may help. I don't
know. But
>> I would just say it gets easier. You
know the first time I had to speak
publicly I was terrified.
>> And uh
>> so were the people when I spoke.
>> Yeah. [laughter] Any of you ever been in
a prayer prayer group where you're in a
circle and they're taking turns and you
know, "Oh no, they're going to come to
me. It's going to be my turn to pray."
And you cannot hear anything anyone else
is saying. All you know is you go, "Two
more people, one more person, then I've
got to pray. What will I say?"
>> Janet says, "Pinch the baby, go to the
bathroom, anything to get out of there."
Is what she used to say.
>> I you know, I think once you start doing
it and you you realize, I didn't die.
These are friends. It gets easier. And
then you start talking to bigger groups,
you realize we're speaking to friends
and you become more relaxed
practice.
>> Just do it. You can add no said it all.
You know, I'm reminded some of you might
have heard that interview. I forget,
pastor, maybe you can help me, but it
was an interview that somebody gave as
an eyewitness, I believe, as a child
hearing Ellen White pray. Does that ring
a bell?
>> Forget who it is. Um,
>> HMS Senior.
>> That's who it was. Yes. It was at a camp
meeting if I remember the story right
and u he was just a a young boy and
Ellen White got to pray. It was her time
to pray and he describes how that there
was a silence that came over the crowd
and she began to pray and it was if it
was just her and God talking.
>> Uh she said my father and she started
praying and there was such a power
people didn't want to open their eyes
lest they see an angel standing beside
her. It was a very sacred time. And I
think the more we pray and the more we
realize that it's not about me, it's
about Jesus. It's about God. We're
sharing with our father who loves us. He
invites us to come into his presence.
That fear of praying publicly begins to
to diminish if we're not worried about
ourselves, right?
>> We're interested in Jesus. All right.
Here's an interesting question, a very
practical one. How do I pray for
complete repentance when there is a part
of me that doesn't really want to
change?
>> Well, a prayer for repentance or prayer
for anything else must be done
wholeheartedly.
You can't pray 75% for repentance and
25% you don't. Jesus said, "Love the
Lord thy God with all thy heart, with
all thy soul, with all thy mind, with
all thy strength, with all thy might,
with all thy understanding." It must be
total. Lloy tells us God requires the
entire surrender of the heart before
justification can take place. And so
when you pray, you pray with all your
heart and soul. And if you can't do
that, ask God to help you to do it.
>> Because spiritual exercises require ask
God to help me to pray with all my heart
and soul.
>> That last statement I shared today,
Christ object lessons 159, is so
powerful. She says we can't rid
ourselves of self. We can't have pure
hearts. We can't even got to give our
God our heart. But we did give God our
heart
>> is what she's saying. Then if we say I
consent today to let you do it, only
Jesus can really do those things for us.
So willing to be made willing is is the
thing. But I I I pray Lord I've given
you my heart, but today I don't feel
like it. And I I want to hang on to this
thing. So you got to you got to do this
thing in me somehow. And I think he
likes that prayer.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. That reminds me of a statement in
steps to Christ. You probably all heard
it. You cannot change your heart. You
cannot of yourself give to God its
affections.
>> But you can choose to serve him.
>> Yes. Consent.
>> And then he will work within you. Right.
And that's a daily experience. You can
say, "Lord, I'm not willing. Help me to
be willing."
>> Amen.
>> And we walk by faith, not by feeling,
not by sight. We walk by faith. We got
to trust in the Lord. All right. Great
question. Can you say something about um
spiritual meditation? What is correct
meditation? Talk about prayer and
meditation. Of course, we know there's a
wrong kind of meditation. What's the
right kind of meditation?
>> Meditation is absolutely vital. You
know, Psalm 1:2,
[clears throat] in his law he meditate
day and night. Meditation is applying
the mind without distraction to some
biblical theme, thinking about it,
asking questions about it, and talking
to God about it. Your mind is fixed on
that thing without any distraction,
external distraction. This is essential
to understand the Bible. It's also
essential for the word of God to go all
the way down to the very foundation of
our minds, the very subconscious. As
Ellen White says, as I told you earlier
today, the reason why we fall into sin
so easily, we do not study the word of
God and meditate upon it. Meditation is
very very important and it's usually
done by yourself in some quiet place.
You the word of God and you're dwelling
on it. What does it mean? What's it
saying to me? What is God trying to tell
me? Is it exposing my sin? You know, you
asking yourself as you're wrapped up in
this thing, dwelling on God's word
without any external distractions.
>> Yeah.
I used to be involved in eastern
religions and meditation in that context
was to empty your mind.
>> They'd give us some mantra to repeat
over and over again that had really no
meaning and pretty soon your mind is
full of like nothing. And biblical
meditation as Elder Ski was saying it's
really the opposite of that. You are
processing the the word of God, the
application of God, the depth of God.
It's really it's thinking about the
truth in God and the nature of God. and
the awesomeness of God uh which is
totally opposite from sort of the
eastern meditation that is even being
taught in some churches today that you
sort of just empty yourself and wait for
feelings and that I think is dangerous.
It's almost the opposite of eastern
meditation where you're emptying your
mind. Uh in biblical meditation, you
filling your mind with the word of God.
And I think the big question is
mentioned is you want to understand what
the verse means. But I think even the
more important question is Lord, how do
I apply this law, this this principle to
my life? Right? [snorts] How do I make
that real? All right. Another question
that we have, can you say something
about the correct posture in prayer? We
talk about kneeling, standing, but
here's even more specific. I've been
told that when I pray, I need to look
towards heaven as Jesus did instead of
bowing down as people do even now. So,
any thoughts on that?
>> The publican in Luke 18, he bowed his
head.
>> He would not so much as lift up his eyes
to heaven, a consciousness of being no
good. So, that's how he prayed. Jesus in
John 11:41 lift up his eyes and pray to
the father. I thank you. So there's no
law that says you must lift your head or
bow your head. It depends on you and
your interaction with God. Um the
posture kneeling, standing, sitting
>> in I mean you're praying in church,
walking. So the postures vary.
>> Pray while you drive, pray while you get
up. Pray while you lie in bed. The Bible
says, "I meditate at night on your
word." So there's no place where you
can't pray. Right.
Do not close your eyes if you're driving
and praying.
>> You know, I must say that feels a little
strange. Our family will be going
somewhere and we need to pray as a
family and you got to keep your eyes
open on the road and everyone else has
their eyes closed in prayer. You know
what I'm talking about. Kind of feel a
lot. But you know, God does hear those
prayers, too. All right. Another
question that we have talking about
prayer and the fruit of the spirit. I
want more of the Holy Spirit. I want the
fruit of the spirit. How does this
connect with prayer? Do I just ask for
it? Lord, give me the fruit of the
spirit.
How many more questions do we have?
>> I'm looking at the clock. We got about
five minutes.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. I hope that wasn't an
illegitimate question. I thought I
answered that earlier. How to get the
Holy Spirit. I thought I comment on
that.
>> You know, they maybe they missed that
part. I don't know. You better recap.
Just a high point.
>> Well, you ask for the spirit. Luke
11:13. You really ask
to you obey God. The spirit is given to
those who obey. Acts 5:32. By the way,
Hebrews 5:9, Christ is a savior to those
who obey. And so, obedience of the word
because the word is spiritfilled. Keep
asking God for the spirit.
And as the spirit is given and he will
be given, you obey the prompings of the
spirit. And the prompting comes through
the word of God. As Elder Bachelor said,
"If any man will do his will, a
willingness to obey what God tells you
through the spirit is essential to the
reception of the spirit. But you must
ask and ask and ask and do those things
that would attract the spirit." And that
fundamental thing is obey God.
>> Amen.
>> There's a difference between the gifts
of the spirit and the fruits of the
spirit. Before be becoming an Adventist,
I worshiped a lot with Pentecostal
churches and they'd asked me if I had
the Holy Spirit. I thought about all the
changes in my life and they wanted to
know, do you speak in tongues?
>> Well, the tongues is one of the gifts of
the spirit, but it's not the fruit of
the spirit.
>> The the fruit of the spirit is in
Galatians 5 22, love, joy, peace,
longsuffering, kindness, goodness,
faithfulness, gentleness, self-control.
Against such there is no law. You'll
find a list of the gifts of the spirit
in first Corinthians and other places.
And that's different. Some people have
the gifts of teaching, gifts of
administration, gifts of tongues, gifts
of interpretation, miracles, and others.
But the fruit of the Holy Spirit, if
you've got God's spirit and love in your
heart, you'll have that self-control.
Everyone can have that while we have
different gifts of the spirit.
>> All right, another practical question
that we have. Uh, Pastor Ski, you might
want to start this one off for us. How
do we practically memorize scripture?
>> We'll get we'll let you get started and
everyone can share because we probably
all do it differently, right? But some
practical ways. How do we memorize
scripture?
>> My way is constant repetition.
Constant repetition. Now Elite tells us
that which at first seems difficult by
constant repetition grows easy
>> and right thoughts and actions become
habitual and so it is constant you know
you ask what my prayer life is like one
of the first things I do in the morning
is recite scripture to God
sometimes I go to the basement my wife
knows I'm in the basement reciting
scripture there's certain chairs in my
house when I sit there I'm reciting a
certain chapter if If I sit over there,
I'm reciting a certain chapter. If I So
I'm always always always going over them
because repet this is no different from
how professional athletes behave. I met
a guy in South Africa. He used to be a
professional golfer. He told me he would
whatever that stroke is, he would hit a
golf ball 600 times every day. Mhm.
>> There's some basketball players who
shoot the ball hundreds of times every
day so that it becomes muscle memory
without thinking.
>> And so it's constant repetition. Ask God
to help you. Be determined. Be
disciplined. By discipline, I mean if
it's raining, you do it. If it's an
earthquake, you do it. If you're dead,
you do it. Whatever it is, you do it.
That's discipline like Nike. Just do it.
And of course, always ask God to help
you.
>> But my fundamental principle is constant
constant repetition.
>> Amen.
>> Yes. Pass it up.
>> I would agree with everything that was
just said. I think um part of scripture
memorization is um just you need to
study. We had a nextdoor neighbor that
had memorized the whole New Testament.
And um he said a few years after he told
me that he he proved it to me. I would
ask him things randomly and he would
just start quoting it. He said, "Well, I
can't do it now because I didn't stay
with it." He says, "You got to
constantly be reading it and
practicing."
But another thing helps us to remember.
If someone says something to you that is
really precious, you remember. I wrote
Karen a poem when we got married and she
remembers the phrases in that poem.
>> And so, you know, there's sometimes
something that really touches your
heart, you're going to remember. When
you're an evangelist and you have a
proof text that the light goes on, it's
easier to remember those verses because
there's this real power to prove a
point. And so, I think there's a variety
of things that help verses stick. It's
easier for for me to remember some
scriptures than others. There's some
parts, you know, if you ask me to tell
you about the genealogy in Chronicles,
I'm sorry. It's really tough, but there
are other verses that, you know, are
very moving that are easier to remember.
So, um, keep reading it.
>> All right. Very good. Share it with
somebody else. That's what helps me.
>> Amen.
>> If you're doing a Bible study and you're
going to be sharing a number of verses
and you're going over it over and over
again, it seems that when you share it,
it seems to stick a little bit better.
>> Amen. Good point. So share the word. All
right. Maybe our final question as we
wrap up here. Good question. What is the
difference then practically speaking
when asking for something? Knowing the
difference between asking in presumption
versus asking in faith.
What's the difference between asking in,
you know, carelessly presumption or in
genuine faith?
I'll just say that is a great question
because um I struggle with that. You
know, Jesus raised the dead and I've
been to a few funerals
>> where I said, "Lord, am I supposed to
try this?"
>> And and you know, you don't want to be
presumptuous because that wouldn't go
very well if it didn't work. Um so
that's an extreme example, but sometimes
we do struggle to know is it a lack of
faith on my part
>> or am I being presumptuous?
You didn't give us an answer, pastor.
>> I know these guys are going to answer
that for you.
>> No simple answer to that one, I don't
think. You know, we got to have a
connection with the Holy Spirit and
abiding in Jesus. I think he he has to
help us have faith. Uh yeah, I remember
somebody came up to me um at church one
day and he was so sincere and he said,
"I I I paid my money and I I played the
lottery and I'm just asking the Lord to
win the million-dollar jackpot." and he
had all of these great mission projects
that he's going to use the funds for.
Had a hard time telling you, brother,
that's probably not a prayer
>> that God's going to answer. Now, that's
an extreme case. Sometimes it's a
legitimate, you know, what do I do now,
Lord? I I want to pray in faith. I want
to be bold. I want to claim your
promise, but I don't want to do it
presumptuously. We still haven't gotten
a good answer yet. You got what's on the
front?
>> The answers were good. Faith is not
believing God will do what you say.
Amen.
>> Faith is believing God will do what he
says.
>> Amen. That's a good point.
>> Some people think they can manipulate
God with faith. I believe this. No, no,
no. Faith is believing what God says,
not that he'll do what you say. You
know, God told the Israelites, "Cross
the Red Sea. He did not tell the
Egyptians to cross." That was
presumption. And they ended up drowned.
Presump. To avoid presumption, keep our
prayers connected to the word of God and
the will of God and the glory of God.
>> That's as far as I can go. The glory of
God, the will of God. Keep your prayers
close to that and you'll avoid
presumption.
>> It it does really u move me that Jesus
said so often, if you abide in me, my
words abide in you, you can ask anything
in my name and I'll do it. I think it's
because we will be so close to Jesus,
have his heart that when we're praying,
we'll know that it's him saying, "Pray
about this." That that's kind of
>> absolutely. Yes.
>> And I was just going to add that when
I'm in doubt about Lord, is this
presumption or is it your will? I say,
"Well, I'm going to do the safe thing.
I'm going to pray in accordance with
God's will and then leave the results
with God." And so do the safe thing, but
don't presume if you jump off the temple
that the angels are going to catch you
because that's called tempting the Lord.
All right. Well, we want to thank all of
you for your great questions and thank
you for our speakers for sharing with
us. This has been a great discussion.
It's been great being able to spend some
time together talking about prayer. I
don't think we talk about prayer enough.
Do you want to say a hearty amen to our
speakers for being with us today?
This has been a rich blessing for us to
be able to gather together and to share.
I want to remind you we're coming to the
end of our time together here. But don't
forget there is the prayer workshop that
is going to be taking place. Breakfast
at 8:30 tomorrow morning starting at
9:00. And you don't want to miss any of
that. We thought maybe it would be
appropriate for us to close out our time
together today by singing our theme
song. You remember Be like Jesus. I'd
like to invite the song leaders to come
out and uh we're going to sing it. Uh
maybe we're going to sing with a piano
and then I'd like to try it ac capella.
Let's stand as we close and then
immediately after the song uh Pastor
Doug if you would have the closing
prayer after the song.
[music]
Teach [music and singing] me father
what to say.
Teach [music] me [singing] father
how to pray.
Teach me [music and singing] all along
the way.
How [music and singing] to be like
Jesus.
>> [music]
>> I [singing] would be like Jesus.
[music] I would be like Jesus. [singing]
Help me Lord [music]
to daily
grow
more [singing] and more like Jesus.
[music]
Teach [singing] me how we may be one
like the [singing] father and the son.
And [singing] when all is overcome,
I will [singing] be like Jesus.
I [singing] would be like Jesus.
I would [singing and music] be like
Jesus.
Help me [singing and music] Lord to
daily
grow
more and more
like Jesus.
[music]
[singing]
Amen. Now, before we have our closing
benediction, by the way, Solomon stood
and blessed the people. So, we're going
to do that. Don't forget, as you leave,
there are some gift books.
>> We do. We have
>> both books. We've got Teach Us to Pray.
It's on the back. We also have
Experiencing God through prayer, Praise,
and His Word. It's available at the
back.
>> And the summit weekend is not over. Come
tomorrow morning, and you will be
blessed. Let's bow our heads together.
Loving Lord, we just want to thank you
again for the evidence we've seen of
your spirit moving that uh Jesus we
believe has been exalted through his
word. Uh we felt our hearts are drawn
closer to thee and we pray you'll
continue to bless as we go from this
place and we have a new week spread
before us. Help us to let your light
shine through us. Bless each person. We
pray that we will see these prayers that
have been brought before you answered
and Lord that we might all be together
in your kingdom. We thank you and ask
all this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> God bless.
[music]